en fait dans un vrai qu'on l'ait
politique et en une heure une heure et
demie on devrait savoir connaître le nom
du prochain chef conservateur on a suivi
cette course là parfois dix ans parfois
de façon plus intensive on sait ça a été
une course extrêmement dur à monsieur
poilievre le char est notamment c'est le
retour de monsieur charest en police et
maman politique important pour toi parce
que ce sera aussi par si ble ment le
prochain premier ministre qu'on va
découvrir ce soir comme chef du parti
conservateur
les libéraux ont déjà trois mandats
derrière eux avoir madeleine des mre
bonsoir dans sa patrie alors oui ce soir
il a été jeté important pour ça parce
qu'il ya le chef du parti conservateur
d'une part may ans époque un jour des
prochaines élections c'est dommage oui
y'a pas une énorme 6 ans patrick pas
très sûr le prochain chez qui on se
demande est-ce qu'il doit être élu en
autour du tout pierre poilievre a mis
sur le coup on verra bien mais moi ce
que je vais surveiller entre autres ce
soir c'est le temps discours de victoire
de pierre poilievre si c'est bel et bien
lui qui est choisie parce qu'on entend
dans le cas inverse au ce qu'il veut
nous tendre la main qu'on veut pouvoir
se sentir bienvenu dans ce parti là donc
c'est dès ce soir qu'il peut faire ce
vol alors je vous montre ce qui était en
lice quand même parce qu'il ya pas que
monsieur charest et monsieur poilievre
jane raison madeleine ce poil hier qu'on
le dit tellement en avance que s'arrêter
impôts c'est pour monsieur charest de le
rattraper il ya laisse les loups risque
est arrivé 3e je le note la dernière
fois romaine b2 et les deux prochaines
quatre à jackson des députés ontariens
qui
voulait se faire valoir romane de beurre
et quai sur la scène provinciale
vers le mandat il avait été exclu après
du gouvernement du caucus conservateur
parce qu'il s'était opposé à des mesures
sanitaires de contrôle sanitaire et ils
étaient devenues indépendantes de ses
ports aux présenté par la suite scott
atchison et un député provincial qui a
été élu pour la première fois en 2010
9,1 tandis qu'on a appris à connaître en
fait durant cette course il s'est fait
connaître comme quelqu'un qui se voulait
rassemble voilà et patrick brown qui a
lancé cette course est elle au départ au
qui a dû quitter parce qu'on l'accusé de
financement d'être allé chercher des
membres de façon irrégulière midi non
lui veut se représenter l'amérique brême
tenu d'ailleurs donc il reste je veux un
peu plus tôt sur rdi au mystère dans mon
esprit comment peut-on être rédigé pour
le poste de maire et qu'on ne puisse pas
être obligé pour le poste de chef de
parti mais bon la population telle étude
exactement et ne touche terre et
continuer sur notre lancée même profil
quand je disais si à la fin nous
dégageons surchargé c'est intéressant
parce que au début de la course jean
charest a dit les meneurs dans les
courses conservatrice ils perdent
toujours été vrai en 2007 parce que
maxime bernier était le meneur mais pour
gagner c'était vrai en 2010 9 parce que
si tu mettais avait t-il bonheur il n'y
avait pas gagné cette fois ci la forme
le post de cette façon on ne refait pas
la même bataille macro le fort si vous
connaissez mesdames et messieurs étaient
venus ancien ministre conservateur
bonsoir mac os chantal hébert hélène
buzzati bonsoir à vous trois tours de
table
si a pas de suspense quant au gagnant ya
un petit suspense quant à lui les tops
ce parti là demain matin est-ce-qu'il
voir dépôt a reconnu et macau force au
départ colis pas sûr mais certainement
des ponts à reconstruire avec certains
joueurs clés notamment des députés du
québec un pied monsieur charest qu'on a
déjà entendu depuis une heure être en
attente le même d'un geste la part de
monsieur poilievre femmes souffrent
beaucoup et le surpoids liem ce soit
mais se gagne au premier tout par un
très grand très grand écart il devrait
quand même faire preuve d'humilité est
allé tout de suite vers ces gens alors
qu'ils ont un pied monsieur charest
s'assurer qu'ils ont une place de choix
d'un parti ou au sein du caucus parce
que déjà la dengue sont très importants
pour la suite jusqu'aux chantal êtes
d'accord parce que là et si ces gens là
ont les yeux rivés sur la vraie bataille
tout les libéraux la prochaine fois vous
verrez qu'ils ont pas encore les yeux
totalement rivés sur la grille battre et
parce qu'ils sont encore dans celle ci
et dans quelle sorte quoi que c'est pas
si ça va donner sous quelle manière donc
oui c'est vrai le discours de monsieur
colère est important surtout que si lui
tend pas la main en personne monsieur
charest sont connus nous on va le faire
et
on va les entendre c'est donc non je
surveillais c'est le langage corporel de
shanghai sa d'importance commentaires
parlent ils de l'histoire qui est en
train de se répéter du meneur enfin moi
j'étais pas dans cette salle 6 mais je
vois l'histoire se répéter ces amendes
parce que j'étais leur quinzième campo a
battu jan chan et désormais je me dis et
trente ans plus tard à douvres et encore
le est on est on ici et ces pauvres
parce que cette fois ci c'est la
dernière voilà ce que j'ai dit s'il
avait
le tour bus
quand même si l'on suppose à surveiller
ce pas ce qui va être important pour la
suite des choses c'est des résultats au
québec les gens de monsieur croyait
vraiment avoir résulté au québec qui dit
j'ai pas besoin de vous il je suis
capable - de gagny des bois auquel et je
sais ce que c'est que la carte maîtresse
campagne alors on va voir dans les
chiffres comme un sac et traduit c'est
la première course au leadership de ce
parti et v unis où le québec est
vraiment engagée une augmentation
spectaculaire sur scène ça de mémoire
une augmentation de 16 1% des membres
peut être à cette course r je vous
montre je vous poste sa parole et hélène
dans une seconde mais je vous
mentionnais le tableau ça c'est
intéressant il si le congrès politique
ou le plus de membres ont voté dans
l'histoire canadienne
418 milles personnes ont exercé leur
droit de vote sur six ans mais le
quelques nouveaux membres et 2 ceci sans
même en y en a à peu près 400 de
nouveaux voiliers lundi donc une
explosion de main mais pourquoi
parce que monsieur poirier avait taillé
chercher de nouveaux membres oui mais
moi je pense que qu'on aime ou qu'on
aime pas monsieur le foyer je trouve
qu'ils ont rendu cette course
intéressante c'est un communicateur r il
a beaucoup tard dessus même j les
réseaux sociaux les laurent gay hétéro
il aux données du home face cette
campagne c'est ici incontestable et
après ce bon et qu'est-ce que sa mesure
pour la partie concernant tant par la
suite vous êtes ce prochain chef sera
peut-être le prochain premier ministre
est ce que je trouve intéressant côté
libéral sait à quel point qu'ils
espèrent que deschacht et et monsieur
payet que ce soit monsieur foyer parce
que les libéraux de justin trudeau sont
convaincus à tort ou à raison qu'ils
peuvent est ce qu était monsieur
poilievre comme un extrémiste qui n'a
pas sa place dans la peau du canada ils
ont déjoué un clin de captage de
salissage et d'ailleurs monsieur
poilievre des jo fait une campagne de
financement de ça ils vont salir donc
donnez-moi de larges déjà commencé si
les résultats sont maintenant connus il
est déjà en campagne sur la campagne et
les
mois écoulés c'est que si c'était jean
charest peut-être que monsieur justin
trudeau songerait à quitter avant la
prochaine élection mais si c'est
monsieur poilievre hillairet ce parce
qu'il pense devoir lui [ __ ] une
dégelée et ils voient ça comme une façon
de défendre son héritage il a dit
madeleine avant tout faire mieux
monsieur trudeau à son à son conseil
je rêve prudemment temps comparé podium
mais quand même c'est un message la bce
attendrait de voir leur dire par exemple
comme si il devait envoyer un message
des troupes à ses députés ceux qui sont
peut être intéressés potentiellement à
le remplacer que c'est pas le moment de
trop s'organiser s'il est encore là pour
quelques quelques temps qu'il veut mener
la bataille et plus d'accord avec hélène
st pierre poilievre a sans cesse pour
pierre poilievre a choisi justin trudeau
est encore plus motivé à la mener cette
bataille quoique chez les libéraux on
dit faut faire attention de potes
définissant comme eux un combat de coqs
comme si c'était la seule motivation que
je suis plutôt parce que la population
veut s'en sert construit aucune d'elles
est bio et non pas que ce soit une
bataille d'ego au large de la
démonisation sur intervenir on a fait ça
on attend cette personne et chaussures
un peu après son élection en 2003 et
l'élection de 2004 est arrivé tout de
suite après la cour souligne j les
libéraux ont gagné une minorité misons
pas été capable de faire l'exercer de la
démonisation par thierno madani surtout
après quinze ans de pouvoir avec les
libéraux ce qui était le cas à l'époque
et ce qui est le cas maintenant elle
mandela l'usure de ce coup droit et on
peut pas faire peur aux gens a
continuellement
faire qui veulent le démoniste ont
répondu samedi c'est au compteur dont on
veut plutôt l'ignorer ce prix
et la faune personnes qui pullulent au
système juste ajouté
quand même parce que justin trudeau
effectivement serait peut-être plus
avant ça c'était jean charest mais aussi
parce qu'il sentirait plus à l'aise à
l'idée qu'il est le canada jean charest
copiapo à lyon c'est pas juste une
question pourquoi ces corps que de la
stratégie ya aussi aussi le
sahel les deux on a aperçu monsieur
poilievre tout à l'heure
assis dans la salle monsieur charest
également les autres candidats sont bien
sûr je le soulignais au début aux ja là
c'est quand même la première fois qu'on
a un vrai congrès 1 3 a
raconté l'ont un peu le déroulement de
la soirée
[Musique]
mais présentement c'est monsieur o'toole
le chef qui ont poussé vers la sortie et
y amener cette course à la direction du
parti conservateur qui s'adresse à la
foule il n'est pas présent monsieur
automne il faut se rendre en france ce
qui est clair c'est que ce soir les
partisans qu on a pu voir jusqu'à
maintenant se déplace avec des pancartes
pour leur fournir le chandail de théâtre
hier j'ai même vu des chandails avec des
gens qui parlaient liberté avec un
camion sur leur chandail
c'est à la majorité bon ça demande un
peu mexique de personnes que pierre
poilievre a attiré les cinq partis
conservateur et ça démontre si et à ce
qui se passe surtout en crever c'est ce
qu'on peut voir qu'il ya un changement
d'attitude dans le camp poil hier on a
vu des députés et des gens de l'équipe
poilievre aujourd'hui avant que la
cérémonie commence à les voir des
députés des gens de l'équipe de monsieur
charest pour avoir des conversations
avec lui est ce que le message que
monsieur poilievre voudrais envoyer ce
soir c'est vraiment un message d'unité
on s'attend dans son discours à ce qu'il
tende la main de langage qui l'utilisera
faudra voir mais il ya déjà des ponts
qui commence à être rapiécé même en
coulisses alors que cette course tire à
sa fin il ya eu des échanges âpres il ya
eu oui voilà les échanges rappeler est
vraiment un des ego qui ont été blessés
dans cette campagne et l'équipe des
mauges fois hier en est conscient et a
déjà commencé à mettre du baume sur la
plaie avec ses adversaires
oui d'ailleurs on pouvait se demander à
la fin de cette cabriole pourquoi ils y
allaient aussi fort parce qu'il y avait
presque certitude rien tu connais
pourquoi attaquer pourquoi accusé ses
adversaires de ne pas être découverte
pourtant on peut se demander aussi si le
pot commencer petit banc ces dernières
heures à essayer de
recoudre et plélan parce que moi ce que
j'entends de la part des gens du camp
charest c'est qu'ils le veulent cette
main tendue
ils sont ils sont vraiment disposés à
essayer de rebâtir le parti et quand je
vois par exemple nous tous y prononcer
un discours et tout le monde se lève
c'est aussi à une tentative de ses
brides mais autour c'est la première
fois que jamais tout simplement si
j'adore ce soir sur une vidéo fright
night là il ya beaucoup de culpabilité
oscillant viré ils l'ont mais cette
crise c'est ce que
a l'air et s on disait que les gens les
députés du québec un nouveau coup qui
ont appuyé monsieur charles êtes vous
attendez le même temps du réel pour
voilà dans quel saint se poiler afghane
comme prévu mais je pense que l'objectif
on est tous des conservateurs
la campagne était heureux vous l'avez
souligné je pense tout le monde le bus
vous avez vous trouvé cette je passerai
oui tu t'es fait puis j'ai fait quelques
sorties publiques même sur le discours
qui était utilisé par un outil
particulièrement dans les réseaux
sociaux je n'ai vécu de façon peut-être
plus intense que d'autres d'entrer à
ceux ci jean charest dans cette pièce là
mais oui il ya des gens puis tente où
vous étiez parler parce que aussi le
fond de ce qui nous anime apolitique qui
est important c'est pô juste de gagner
notre siège ou dette du gouvernement et
la façon aussi de faire la politique
donc c'est pas juste une main tendue de
dire jal est important dans
l'organisation dans un gouvernement mais
ce genre de policiers on va faire un
petit conservatoire à partir de
maintenant pour rejoindre de plus de
cases est passé à vue dans leurs
messages que vous envoyez à votre
prochain chercher là c'est pas le temps
d'une torpillé prétend nous amener avec
zhu a mené avec vous oui c'est la
première des choses ma pression de
quelle façon on va s'adresser à la
population canadienne de quelle façon on
va essayer d'aller chercher des nouveaux
soyez qui vont vouloir voter
conservateur pour qu'on puisse agrandir
cet ami l'a ainsi un jour retourner au
gouvernement donc il ya toute cette
façon faire la politique qu'on le voit
cette tendance si je dis que je voulais
parler j'ai fait une lettre ouverte par
rapport à ceux la police etc un peu plus
à l'américaine on voit la tendance cet
internement
dans des pme parce que pouvez vous
imaginer à l'aise avec son leadership
rob estes effet si le chien changement
dans la façon par la politique quand je
serai centrage et qui va acter que je
pense qu'on peut tous laissé la chance
au coureur est ce que vous y croyez à se
re familiariser le mou recentrage comme
si pour vous c'est tout à fait normal et
c'est pas juste le recentrage sur les i
politique sur la façon de faire de la
politique la façon de s'adresser aux
gens je pense que je dis moment où on
doit s'y lui comme politicien comme
comme analystes politiques journalistes
comme le leader dans la communauté ce
qu'ils ont dit post lee condemi croûte
peuvent s'adresser à la population mais
malheureusement je pense qu'à certains
moments certaines personnes et je peux
parler juste depuis à pau lièvre
il
est ce qu'ils les ont décrits depuis il
changera pas à l'aise avec lui à ce jour
je répète ça va être ce qui va proposer
dans une organisation
la structure il est du crime au regard
de la taille dans une entreprise le
directeur général le directeur d'une
école le pdg de naftal sa part de l'odon
ça va être les responsables prochain
cher d'envoyer s'ils allaient partir de
ce moment alors les députés les
sénateurs liste woillet vont prendre une
décision par la suite à l'exploit pour
conducteurs façon ça va être aussi
augmentation de 7 1% des membres ou
cuivre est donc
charest a dû être responsable jolie
partie cette augmentation
c'est ce pour alien ou si il était
appuyé au québec ou 6 puis partout au
canada il était suivi avait demandé
récemment gueule une fascination face à
ce côté très carré très direct vous le
voyez vous sentez cette aide à
la population qu'une colère la pandémie
exaspéré 8 est exaspéré sort ce c'est
clair maintenant que mon la canaliser
cette colère le pkk est ce qu'on propose
à ces gens là c'est le cas je t'aime je
mentionne la pression de faire de la
politique dont ces gens là sont
mobilisés qui veulent envoyer un message
experte raison je suis sans arrêt des
lycées moi je ne remets pas en question
ce je pense que oui avec toutes les
centrales ttp dans les gouvernements ou
mises aux questions des journalistes
sont plein de fois cas de pose des
questions lui dans les options c'est
extrêmement frustrant c'est plus dès
lors je pense qu'il faut que la colère
se transforment en propositions
positives en année politique
le mot liberté on l'utilisé pour lutter
en tous les sens mais bon je laisse
encore dans ce pays où je me concert
extrêmement libre mais je peux
comprendre pour une sorte de connotation
je pense que manu offrant sortie de mon
liberté pour leur dis mais qu'est ce
qu'on propose pour protéger cette
liberté condat et services que l'on note
que le neuf aux citoyens avec une vision
qui concilie
environnement tour donc les parce qu'on
s'entend aussi le texte rapport associe
vous dans les prochains mois vous ne
voyez pas ce discours ce ton se mettre
en place je prendrai mes décisions je
prends ça va toujours être dans mon
corps je vais rester en fond sont mes
valeurs personnelles dans un parti
politique on adhère à 10 10 mais ont
réussi avec nos propres valeurs qui est
des choses qui nous animent la ville et
la police et qu'il ya autour les
politiques aussi donc
je me sens pour les matchs et je me sens
à lire je me sens heureux en ce moment
mais je dis aussi combien déjà à
à soigner certaines zones basses pas
nécessairement maintenant votre visage
comme candidat prochain iphone je n'ai
pas sur cette décision le jury computer
avec comme le stedelijk la coalition au
cordeau pour le bac à vaisselle
oui il y en a qui s'amusent à des cas
des rumeurs à l'automne prochain mais
besoin pour les fédérales non mais
[Applaudissements]
c'est que vraiment beaucoup de bonne
volonté des libéraux et les
néo-démocrates de la sphère du risque
pour l'édition la plus qu'un inde j'ai
vraiment l'impression qu'on essayait
mettre en place les programmes qu'elles
sont démocrates en ce moment mais je
sens de la merci demande à part de rêve
c'est de choquer les attaques dont celle
qui vous avez trouvé vraiment c'est ça
tacle très dur personnel mais reste tout
est fait non mais je doute confirme le
puits lui permettait jeu 3 2 secondes
lorsqu on s'attend du québec moulins on
le voit l'oeil hamouma qui part tout
aussi exigeant madame à cette fonction
qui dit clairement ce sera l'un des
suspects le parti conservateur du québec
j'ai fait le choix de rester neutre dans
la course concernant toutes les autres
campagnes je leur lance la balle au bond
j'allais voir les gens qui m'attaque sur
les réseaux sociaux vous allez voir un
canot plusieurs sur le bout parce qu'on
s'entend du québec où le goût avec le
convoi tup himo liberté ou qui a pallié
avec son groupe qui est là oui
comprendre que maintenant on est tous
des êtres humains à profit ses audiences
et joan baez je ferai ma famille c'est
juste qu'en serbie est ce que vous
voulez entendre toute cette réflexion là
je pense c'est important pour la science
avait surpris qu'il y ait aussi peu je
dis que tu es l'extérieur qui vécut un
steam ce char et oublions le discours
des gens autour de monsieur poilievre
mes jambes gros ça m'a surpris
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on ne prenait pas ici de jouer cette
guerre ne le fait que monsieur chars
étaient tous à l'extérieur la joute
politique et ou privés qui dit payer ses
sensibilités par là qu'on travaille on
pas ça motive notre année on pense tout
le temps souvent tu as côtoyé cfo de
nous rejoindre nos conjointes genre de
délit d'initié déjà qu'ils supportent
une personne peu juste pour visiter ou
c'est parce qu'ils y croient ce
personnage parce que ce sont des ennemis
est personnelle à travers ce qui c'était
un travail on a pressé de faire unique
r2 qui a le plus de députés toutes
manières garder un
regard des quatre courses à la chefferie
sérum à celui qu'elle faisait mais ok
donc vous allez écouter chaque mot du
discours de monsieur soit les aime ça se
confirme il est important pour vous qui
qui baissent d'un ton oui ma tasse que
matin sketchbooks rassemblant je pense
que quel que soit le gagnant c'est
l'objectif unités apprécié de voir
comment ça va se concrétiser
qu'est ce que ça va durer je pense que
c'est ça que plusieurs personnes
philippe canetti canadienne surtout vous
regardez dans les prochaines semaines
prochaines
jusqu'à fois c'est son entourage ou si
vous le sait fort mais c'est ça aussi
mais c'est clair sous-entendu aller le
chef de chaîne les partis politiques
étaient entourés de stratège c'est beau
tout seul sinon c'est pour nous
mais fait pour mettre fin à la page mais
xavi ou certains sont en fin de compte
je reviens à ce plateau le leader a
rossé du kilomètre sélection s'est
enquis des dix ans commencée vick qui
doit surtout donné notre temps j'ai
commandé par la police ils le font à
l'intérieur de la famille conservatrice
mais ça valait peloton aussi adopter
face à tous les canadiens est ce que les
canadiens vont vouloir moi j'ai utilisé
le mot football tout à l'heure parce
qu'on a souvent qualifié terreau poyet
football est ce que la population
canadienne beau vouloir avoir ce genre
de leader très combatif lors qu'ils ont
une autre temps précieux mieux parfois
parce que ça peut plaire à une partie du
même bauchi conservateur est ce que ça
te plaire à la population en général
jusqu'à maintenant on a senti un
engouement chez les conservateurs et
dans les sondages c'est presque le calme
plat que sinon on peu près le même
nombre de personnes le même pourcentage
de personnes qui appuient les
conservateurs que les libéraux ce qu
avant la course à la chefferie donc et
pas eu cet engouement dans les sondages
sur la scène général dans la population
canadienne en général la dernière fois
qu'il ya eu comme stop de conscience
elle s'inquiète un banquier et tout le
monde s'est entendu pour rire c'était le
chef de l'opposition officielle le plus
efficace qu on avait bu et il était
vraiment très peu ce côté avec steve est
un peu et puis lendemain des élections
eh bien merci beaucoup d'ajustements
immersive où la politique est un sport
rude on l'a on le voit on le voit et
dans les médias sociaux
son prix du café beaucoup les réseaux
sociaux merci d'abus sur le plant
officiant noël jette avec un stratège
conservateur justement quelqu'un qui
travaille avec pierre bavière
voilà c'est vous dire si je préfère
conservateur qui travaillé avec pierre
poilievre dans l'opposition vous parliez
de solitude de crevin rodilhan non
monsieur polaire se jette pour améliorer
notamment ses disques à écouter monsieur
de polyèdres se préparer pendant des
heures si vous remarquez pendant la
période des questions il ne lit jamais
son papier il le mémorise et à une
éthique de travail je pense que c'est
quelque chose que les députés respecte
énormément moi je les ai vus pendant des
heures dans le lobby un peu pratiqué
pour vraiment réussir à avoir maîtrisé
ce 35 secondes et à la fois il est
capable de faire un travail de longue
haleine sais pas si vous vous souvenez
on est dans l'opposition avec soin des
chiens on voulait bloquer le budget je
sais pas si ça vous dit quelque chose il
ya il a parlé pendant des heures et des
heures quand ce qu'on appelle en anglais
si les bosquets essayé de bloquer pour
bloquer mais il ya plus cité des
discours de churchill et parler avec une
culture et cette erreur sans notes sans
notes c'est sa partition celle de
préparation de son style un peu
batailleur dont parlait madeleine ya
quelques minutes est-ce que ce style
batailleur là qu'on voit en public
présentement il est capable de le
transformer en style unificateur quand
il parlera son caucus oui oui parce que
bien évidemment monsieur payet va avoir
son caucus à avec lui dans l'épreuve des
prochains jours il va pouvoir une
discussion c'est sûr c'est pas le même
style que vous voyez à l'appel des
questions sous des portes sous des
portes closes mais je pense que les
députés respecte l'éthique de travail de
pierre poilievre parce que c'est vrai
qu'il y met l'effort il connaît ses
dossiers connaît ces chiffres en tant
que critique des finances déconner ces
chiffres sur les doigts de la main les
statistiques qui peut voler cité et je
pense que c'est quelque chose que tous
les députés respecte et qui va amener le
synthétique de travail là comme nouveau
chef et en coulisses on dit qu'il est
drôle oui oui oui non il est drôle il
est trop juste dans sa préparation dans
ses imitations un peu comme ça et c'est
un peu de pain un peu comme ça essayer
de voir comment les choses vont se
dérouler salle et il anticipe beaucoup
monsieur payet moi je les ai vus dans sa
préparation est ici à l'époque toujours
en français il ya toujours voulu
s'exprimer en français toujours dans les
deux langues chose que certains députés
ne font pas tous les lieux c'est quelque
chose que depuis le début
ces questions en français en anglais
pour avoir cet exercice là ça fait
longtemps qu'ils se préparent merci
beaucoup monsieur c mais revoilà
pâtissent
merci merci beaucoup oui et je pense
tout le monde qui qui l'ont côtoyé
c'est un homme intelligent vous avez
travaillé avec lui m'a coaché
poilievre ouais j'ai travaillé avec lui
tu es quelques semaines que j'étais ici
il était très jeune à l'époque il était
tombé dans l'oeil de très tôt parce que
c'était quelqu'un à qui un peu confie
des missions impossibles sept personnes
qui étaient toujours qu'ils aient
toujours oui et non
[Applaudissements]
e
il a fait confiance et de lui sur ce que
tu as par le mans est très efficace
pendant qu'on a vu qu'un 10 bergen donc
chef intérimaire qu'il va parler aux
militants dans la salle aussi va faire
en quelque sorte c'est d'ailleurs été
élu cinq fois d'un bug c'est des gens
qui ont une longue histoire mais je le
fais bon à la leçon une tâche ingrate
parfois est intérimaire ouais mais
revenons à l e et l'oeil 4 ici je pense
lorsqu'elle est arrivée après un automne
il fallait essayer de garder une
certaine unité dans ce parti là et j'ai
l'impression que les gens lui ont laissé
sa chance ça c'est quand même assez bien
passé pour le parti conservateur après
le départ des rental parce que les
couteaux carey nous tous le recevait
dans le doubs ça devait faire mal et il
était plus il était il n'avait plus
d'autorité chef donc je pense qu'après
lui n'importe qui finalement été avait
un peu plus de terry si quelqu'un est
monsieur poilievre cette fois ci était
prêt puis je ne dis pas que lancer des
couteaux de lui-même en tout cas les
gens qui employait vont lancer des
couteaux ils étaient près la dernière
fois les gens s'en souviennent pas il a
été en lice pour l'autre course
ici moi je l'avais reçu en entrevue le
vendredi et le dimanche de 10 jeux pour
des raisons familiales j'ai aussi de ne
pas plonger c'est qu'ils n'étaient pas
prêts d'un homme calculateur il sentait
que les choses n'étaient pas en place
et les plus fournis bonsoir % on parlait
des sondages tout à l'heure parce que la
question existentielle avait
conservateurs l'ont jamais vu mais c'est
la prochaine fois se tue pas vous rend
les comtés libéraux beaucoup de
questions est ce que ça fait bouger
l'aiguillé pour les consommateurs à voir
son cours en cours non et c'est très
important de le dire parce que les
conservateurs sont embarqués dans la
plus grande émission de d'agrandir la
bastille en termes de membres et
lorsqu'on regarde la progression des
sondages à moins des sondages à ce point
ici c'est 1 2% libéral train de tout
sans conservateur rien ne bouge au delà
de certains officiers moi ya pas eu lieu
j'ai paniqué mais il n'y a pas eu de
pertes ont plus prêté avec tous ses
symboles des pépites ce qui est des
gains il se bat on a vu dans le passé
des parties s'enchaînent avoir un petit
boost dans les sondages en nos vies sont
un peu courts de juillet mais les
sondages de juillet s'est pas vraiment 6
4 à la question est-ce que poilievre qui
de poilievre charest fait mieux face
trudeau je pense qu'il ya eu un chandail
cette équipe l'équipe de chars et lala
l'excuser demain mes trois lièvres
samuel sarr est en fait lorsqu'on
regarde les ici on le compare en fait
c'était links with qui avait 7 est aussi
chargé et qui cherche puisque ses
connotations de vote même chose pour
foyer avait envoyé que les deux chefs
avaient le même score 34 pour ça chacun
cependant jean charest s'est fait mal
aux libéraux mais il perdait une partie
de la droite à maxime bernier alors au
final ont volé chez très légère
présentement c'est être encore pour ça
charest et poilievre pour les
conservateurs mais jean charest
descendez les libéraux à 24% alors que
les libéraux restent un seul cd ce
sondage de la firme qui a pu un peu un
penchant pour les conservateurs je
dirais dans la moyenne du chien éléments
là d'un tandem que je trouvais
intéressant parce qu'avec jean charest
louis les conservateurs auraient perdu
au parti au profit du parti populaire
mais dans des convoqués qui était garnie
conservateur de toute manière de façon
très notable et on se répond nous faut
faire des sièges par contre que monsieur
charest soit afin d'aller chercher des
vox de vidéos sauf ça
la montée que jean charest s'est valu au
clos très haut niveau au québec jean
charest que gagner la classique faisait
mieux que poilievre ontario alors qu'il
faire défoncer désespoir en alberta où
les consommateurs
mais c'est amusant charest de dire qu'il
était mieux placé pour gagner les
prochaines élections je suis un gars
bien
pour gagner encore possible à gagner la
première course la première étape elle
est aussi importante il faut convaincre
les membres et c'est comme si les
membres étaient pas prêts à voir ce
genre de parti conservateur plus
centristes comme si le parti s'est quand
même tasser vers la droite depuis
plusieurs années je dirais et renault
toul ont mené la dernière fois une
campagne à droite sachant que c'est
comme ça qu'ils allaient gagner le
leader ce petit parti aux filles de
recentrer par la suite pour gagner les
élections et s'arrêter et s'est fait
montrer la force dans t'es vraiment un
exercice a pas de retour du crg moi je
te comprend
les membres de ne pas se laisser
influencer par ces sondages pour saper
les deux dernières sélections par ce
conservateur avec des candidats à la
chefferie qui c'est on va la mettre des
candidats cependant quelle paix mais pas
des gens de grande stature ont quand
même dû réaliser de bons scores au
suffrage universel donc le chalet de
dire que moi j'ai réussi à vous donner
le 2 3 4 60 plus les jeux sont dit on
peut peut-être la voie avec poilievre
ses poses suffisance son était déjà aux
portes et c'est ça qui est je pense bien
monsieur charest si tu fais pour faire
cet expert parce que les gens se sentent
déjà
allons ça fait plusieurs élections qui
sont à la soirée william fait t on avec
l'inflation on avait le chaos dans les
aéroports
on avait des livres des bureaux de
passeport qui était débordé et parti
libéral avec un chef qui a quand même
déjà fait trois élections donc il ya
quand même une certaine usure du pouvoir
et il y avait par mail encore une fois
stabilité dans les sondages moi je
trouve que c'est pas nécessairement bon
signe pour le parti conservateur il va
falloir qu'il faut que je travaille
encore plus fort monsieur chance et le
disait oui un vote c'est un vote sauf
quelqu'un en externe si les sièges qui
l'emportent ils y chiffres qu'on a
présentement nous indique que même si le
parti conservateur pourrait gagner
l'élection pour un point et deux points
ou 3 points ou 4 points mais quand même
perdu deux sièges parce qu'il faut
gagner dans les centres urbains et dans
les banlieues et jusqu'à maintenant
parce conservateurs
on le rappelle en ontario là le résultat
dont herriot la dernière fois été
décevant est-ce que poilievre que par
mesure de faire des gains l'ontario
et ils doivent fabriquer la tascom
centre restera de trois élections et
sans faire des percées là dedans les
conservateurs un parent pauvre mais le
québec aussi au jeu son camp au
printemps pour acquis que les
conservateurs sont plafonnées à 18
sièges au québec alors qu on voit à
lacets sur la scène provinciale la quête
une emprise très grand sur le québec et
la cac qui convainc pas un parti
certains prêtaient une certaine affinité
avec les conservateurs d'ailleurs y
avait invités à voter pour le parti
conservateur il ya un potentiel
important
on continue aux manches et j'ai dit que
c'est la plus dense et des conservateurs
de l'autre aux branchies sur ces canaux
vu porter
le fer ce pont avec les réelles chez les
hommes parce que pour la première fois
que j'écris
première
ce matin
qui va pouvoir converser de façon sans
qu'on en parle
je n'en parle jamais
le fait d'avoir un chef par cette fazila
c'est un soulagement pour ce parti oui
mais c'est le français de pierre fois
hier il est parfait et si l'époque
québécois mais
alors il est extrêment traitement en
français on a vu je l'avais mentionné
parce que c'est la hausse fulgurante
demain au parti conservateur 750 pour ça
on est passé de 7000 je pense à cinq ans
quelques 1057 mais demandent donc une
base là qu'il fait aller chercher tout
en maintenant l'appui de tous ceux qui
ont appuyé dans chargé donc moi j'ai vu
ce soir à est redit avec au début de
l'émission gérard deltell qui était tout
à fait disposé à recevoir une main
tendue mais aussi à l'ariège qui ce sens
je pense plus blessé et qui a l'air et
est atteint la main tendue et des
excuses
c'est pas juste ce n'est pas juste la
main tendue c'est la façon de faire la
politique en général et on sent qu'il ya
du travail à faire juste ma pour essayer
de garder ce mot l'état qu'ils ont dit
quand on dit que j'ai promise pendant
qu'on voit la chef intérimaire qui ont
des besoins qui vont aller parler les
p'tits câlins
1 tandis que diego m'a mis ça dans un
compte aujourd'hui sur dix passent aussi
bref il a les allures de drame
il ya ce côté là ancien journaliste
pourra dire joue avec
ses pilotes
usine encore incertain mais pour qu'elle
débouche sur quelque chose on côtoie
beaucoup plus beaucoup généralisée
envers les étés position les médias est
ici sont à différents on va l'écouter le
début du discours de cadix ou dos rond
et on revient ensuite les messieurs les
résultats devrait nous arriver d'ici une
vingtaine de minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci énormément
j'aimerais commencer par reconnaître que
je suis vraiment effondré par le décès
de sa majesté elizabeth ii elle a servi
avec honneur c'était vraiment notre
reine ne fait aucun doute que ça me
place là où elles se retrouveront la
place en fait dans l'histoire du canada
sera tout aussi importante que celle de
la reine victoria qui l'a précédée
alors j'espère qu'on va pouvoir
encourager la dignité la grâce dont elle
a fait preuve tout au long de sa vie
michael et moi même nous pensons
vraiment à la famille
de la reine et roi qui la remplacera
alors merci énormément
de vos mots vraiment très chaleureux je
suis vraiment plein de gratitude own
vous et moi même sommes amis très
proches depuis des années puisque nous
travaillons au sein de ce parti et j'ai
eu comme avec beaucoup de conservateurs
nous n'étions pas toujours d'accord mais
nous nous sommes toujours
montré du respect nous avons fait preuve
de loyauté à l'égard d'une des causes et
c'est ce qu'en font les conservateurs
nous avons beaucoup ri nous avons aussi
pleuré manger ensemble et avons
poursuivi les conversations tard le soir
donc
donc nous sommes très heureux de vous
pour vous
alors voilà elle s'adresse aux militants
remerciements d'usagé
on sent d'ailleurs parenthèse dans le
déroulement de la soirée sud est avec
nous il ya deux ans vous en souviendrez
fini aux petites heures du matin à tous
tout se déroule exactement presque à
l'heure donc on est vraiment c'est du
papier à musique depuis le début alors
on nous promet les premiers et les
premiers résultats du premier tour
autour de 19h30 trois là c'est très dur
c'est un sujet non quand même la
dernière fois
c'est dans les annales mois de c'est la
première fois de ma vie où j'ai dit je
ne sais plus quoi dire
c'était la première fois comme le jour
ses batteries la presse
je fais des bougies je veux vous avant
de vous laisser aller sur les sondages
oui
stratèges conservateurs robertsau il se
dit une maman 4,5
c'est important pour gagner
poilievre ça de sa toiture notre station
partir de maintenant donc ouvrir et pour
fermer les exactement
quelques minutes par rapport au québec
on voyage on les entend monter dans les
sondages vont peut-être foyer du mc sert
mal le même public mais ça se recroisent
avec la caq aussi et donc moi je suis
prêt puisque son équipe je verrai pour
les libéraux et le bloc québécois au
québec sélectif à montréal et banlieues
québec ccg ont un look très fertile pour
voter conservateur aux prochaines
élections et avec la qualité de son
français de son message il pourrait
faire des percées il faut gagner 12
sièges mais tout à gagner 25 x de
masquer la majorité sur toi comme dit
hélène si le québec des bars la portion
ça peut changer persiste à croire que le
bloc québécois en haïti en tout cas
certainement la dernière élection une
espèce de stationnement il y avait
beaucoup de lassitude envers justin
trudeau ont cherché une alternative
on ne le peut trouver en gitan et en
vélo tout et on s'est replié sur le bloc
mais je pense qu'ils ont le potentiel
parti le bloc québécois n'a jamais été
c'est quand même une coalition à la base
des coalitions de centre parfois d'auge
de passer un peu de droite aussi il se
retrouve sur plusieurs politiques avec
les conservateurs c'est une que doit
viser parce qu'on savait
que je passais au québec avant le débat
ou une douche il s'est carrément planté
dans les cinq premières minutes les
conservateurs étaient autour de 25% et
le sondage ça ça fait beaucoup de sièges
dans l'évangile et on verra comment les
élections provinciales vont se dérouler
comment le parti provincial conservateur
vaut faire dans l'instant les scores est
ce que ça pourrait donner la permission
à des électeurs de dire ok c'est correct
de voter conservateur comme si ça
débloque finalement quelque chose de
psychologique de dire ok voici
conservateurs au québec c'est faisable
alors ça c'est probablement ce que
souhaitent des stratèges conservateurs
mais on verra bien parce que les
libéraux par exemple j'utilise souvent
la carte de bt pas pour le parti
conservateur s'est en particulier par
alors ç'a fonctionné pendant quelques
élections est ce que ça ferait
fonctionner encore cette fois-ci vous
parlez débat on parlait de l'avortement
la dernière fois c'était les attraper
donc à chaque fois en direct du libéro
réussissent à trouver le maillon faible
le suppo aliev sur la question de
l'avortement est moins
pendant la course au début j'avais
laissé planer un petit hôtel mais sinon
choisis sont encore une fois merci
beaucoup absolument j'étais guinée
s'évacuer s'évacuer quoique il est
serait quand même certaines dax cède à
ses textes et il s'est toujours
passé que certaines scènes et que si ça
avait été de ces noms la ligne de
démarcation ce ne sera pas
la plus claire l'environnement le climat
le secteur de l'énergie
je poilievre comme monsieur charest
d'ailleurs v6 on ouvrir un nom on crée
des pipelines ça sera une ligne de
démarcation qui est du beru bas et
l'économie je commençais par l'économie
ici monsieur paul y est il va devoir se
débarrasser rapidement de ces habits de
bitcoin et du travail parce que
honnêtement c'est pas de nature d'un
homme d'état ils vont peut-être devoir
trouver quelqu'un candidat ou une
candidate
je pense qu'elle
est petite en tout cas pas réduit comme
éteint un qu'un critique en matière de
finances qui est exceptionnel mais
monsieur poilievre de plus selon moi
score il ne pas s'être expliqué leurs
papilles wallraff louis seront là dans
la course quand cette fois ci je pense
pas qu'il a eu un impact majeur
lorsqu'il a appuyé pierre courir dans la
course mais il a pu lui donner sa
crédibilité en matière économique qu'il
avait lorsqu'il était premier ministre
et moi dans le camp de pierre poyet rom
odyssea sauf que ça a servi toutes les
questions de d'abord justement si vous
non plus ils y allaient à davos au forum
économique mondial donc et tout d'un
coup en appuyant caire foyer faisait
c'est comme si chili chili le camp
poilievre on avait l'impression de
savenay un peu donné de gueule de
l'oxygène sur la question de la city
pense qu'il va prendre quelques adultes
dans la pièce alors monsieur berck était
ainsi qu'aux présidents pour monsieur
grève du sytral la place si monsieur
harper et là monsieur bergé le long
comme en savoir plus d'adultes dans la
pièce mais servi aux messages dont tu
parlais tantôt mesurer et alors il va
falloir qu'il ya monsieur paul yav
envoie un message très clair que la
façon dont pouvoir converser avec les
canadiens qu'avec nos adversaires faut
que ça change et des gens comme apple
ebay peuvent l'aider à ces gars là mais
peuvent aussi les disques des questions
politiques mais en même temps le
traitement qui a été réservé à être face
qui était quand même une personnalité
avec une certaine stature économique un
ancien du lycée prononcer comme sarah
cette façon qu'on a envie de le tasser
de l'amphi le dit et et la banque du
canada dit qu'on n'a pas d'alluré ça
laisse présager de beaux futures stars
et les sensibilités économique et des
gens pour l'incarner prochaine campagne
s'amuser recense que l'enjeu au delà de
l'économie je pense que c'est celui des
finances publiques je crois que c'est
seul point faible de monsieur rap c'est
de monsieur trudeau les déficits
existence n'a m'a élevé des gens qui ont
la passion qu'on ne verrait jamais la
lumière de tout cela je vois moi là un
potentiel pour le parti conservateur
plus que la question de l'économie qui
quand même roule à plein régime non
canal j qui ont acheté des maisons
d'obsèques surprise moi c'est ça tu vas
ria non mais c'est une grosse dépense
vous l'armement dans les années
précédentes place et importe ce sont des
électeurs trois kilos yoyo commun
disponibles que ce qu'ils voient
l'extérieur un taux de chômage très beau
mais le dans leur maison arrêtés sont
très inquiets sur la leur capacité de
payer leur hypothèque joindre les deux
bouts oui les finances publiques les
licences personnel et on a besoin de
quelqu'un à l'hôtel avec selon l'ap avec
des zéros est ce parce que je reviens ce
monsieur molière et la crédibilité qui
va devoir regagner les canadiens tout ce
qui touche l'économie merci
est ce qu'on sera encore dans une crise
de finances personnelles sociales a
grandi à voir mais il a perdu mais sur
la crédibilité oui avec le big boss mais
avec un traitement le gouverneur la
banque du canada on peut dire je ne suis
pas d'accord avec ceux ci mettent
ailleret jets peuvent elles me disaient
qu'ils donnent ils les trient il est
vraiment un anti establishment lorsqu'on
regardait du populisme ce qui est
intéressant par exemple je pense à
stephen rapp rocky ce rendez vous au
forum économique mondial de davos il
était aussi anti institutions lorsqu'il
avait annoncé la mort c'est elliott
disant qu'il allait reporter l'âge de la
retraite de 65 à 67 ans et à l'époque on
s'était dit oh mon dieu il ne respecte
pas l'institution du parlement il aurait
dû lait annoncé une pareille annonce au
parlement pierre poilievre une coche
plus loin non seulement il lui montre
qu'il est anti establishment entier
institutions mais il est anti davos ou
celle qui les irrite aller plus loin les
solutions hp avait ce côté là aussi qu'à
lui
l'assemblée générale de nations
il était mort canal avoir dû vraiment
dans un mois les choses déconnecté à new
york avenue mais aussi très différent de
paris suivi trois lieux du pays dans le
monde sont qui ont adopté des tonnes
comme devise de la république
centrafricaine et le salvador or je
pense pas que pierre poilievre par deux
sur partout n'aurait jamais fait ça
patrice jamet c'est très différent de
palau nations unies ban ki moon même
chose avec la danse à la radio n'était
pas lui qui tenait d'abord ce poison
qu'on veut nous dire quoi faire au
canada y était question de là d'abord
pour servir pourtant il y aurait des
gens d'affaires qui était à davos des
gens de partout à travers le monde qui
citait le sujet important qui affecté vu
le canada met donc en avant mais selon
monsieur police nous a dit aussi afin de
motivation et on me disait c'est que
c'est des choses qu'on aussi pour
fouetter l'ardeur des prix et ce sans
que des rangées avec monsieur poilievre
cette impression qu'il lançait une sorte
de message jusqu'au drame ont rameuté
toutes sortes de personnes seront
nécessairement élu ou pas d'un
exactement 12 13 juin dean hachamovitch
je leur ai fait maintenant des messieurs
on va pas vous tenir en haleine jusqu'à
l'île
mais
ce sera l'autre en orange avait du
nouveau sur la suite des choses
voilà d'information supplémentaire qui
vient notamment du camp clerck wire mais
aussi de partis d'opposition qui ne
comprennent que je crois que la chambre
reviendra siéger jeudi pour rendre
hommage à la reine il y aurait pas
nécessairement que derrière des
questions mais simplement une série de
matchs et par tous les partis de
compétition y compris le nouveau chef
conservateur qui sera élu ici ce soir
pour le moment il est possible de
rejoindre les gens du parti libéral et
du gouvernement pour confirmer que c'est
le cas mais trois des partis
d'opposition pour le moment nous disent
que la chambre reviendra jeudi et le cas
de pierre poilievre s'il est élu ce soir
espère qu'en tant que chef de
l'inconscient ciel monsieur trudeau
l'invitera à se joindre à lui à londres
pour des funérailles de sa majesté la
semaine prochaine les attend de voir
évidemment un sylvain gagné et 2 si
monsieur trudeau fera cette invitation
c'est leaf en 2020 information n'a pour
le moment fait partie des questions qui
nous disent que la chambre reprendra
jeudi on attend la confirmation du
gouvernement
c'est intéressant christian et la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
combien de canadiens
ancien premier ministre de ses
militaires sur un drop pourront se
rendre aux funérailles de la reine
de plus que la gouverneure générale par
exemple à ce qu'elle fera ce voyage elle
aussi il ya un protocole qui se met en
place et mutuellement dans ce genre de
situation il leur faudra voir qui sera
évitée et qui participera ce voyage
très bien crise faire merci beaucoup je
disais que ça dans 10 12 15 minutes
kristen vous toujours là
autour de vous aller glaner la ce que
c'est c'est ça va rondement parce que
les résultats ils les connaissent les
organisateurs ils ne sont pas très de
compte et tout ça est déjà compté mis
sur une feuille ou natta de talent et la
portée aux prises dans des entrelacs
mais alors que la dernière fois comme
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin cette merci
boc la dernière fois mardi ils ont reçu
les ventes ils ont commencé à les
compter les mercredis jeudis vendredis
pour être sûr que aujourd'hui quelque
chose qu'ils ont à faire c'est réputé
sur le bouton pour d'avoir des résultats
je voudrais dans la fable le sentiment
d'anticipation de pouvoir de ton pouvoir
lancer des cris de joie pour le cercle a
été choisi et dans les deux cas ce
qu'ils ont l'impression d'avoir déjà
perdu je dirais que certaines puces
casse peut-être pas d'amertume mais
[Applaudissements]
voilà que les jeunes y terminer son tour
remerciements à ses collègues du caucus
de toute une vie politique qu'elle adule
et fatima laden j'en parlais d'un
château à bruxelles alors qu'on avait
chassé un chef alors
réussi à apaiser l'intérêt mid
[Applaudissements]
et elle même jamais
songez à se présenter l efo bilingue
alors je sais c'est qu'elle ici d'une
certaine façon politique d'une grande
façon
[Musique]
oui mais on espérait que ce soit le
critère le bilinguisme quoique l'a
jamais dit officiellement
je peux revenir rapidement sur la
question de la crédibilité économique de
pierre poilievre parce que ce que je
trouve intéressant dans pierre poilievre
c'est qu'il amène quand même ce discours
économique avec l'inflation le justin
fashion son slogan le juste inflation il
l'a martelé pendant des semaines à la
chambre des communes et j'ai
l'impression que ce soit ou tard même
être une vulnérabilité pour les libéraux
qui ne l'ont pas vu venir tant que
l'inflation qui était pas tout à fait
prêt à y perdre l'âme les américains les
européens tout à fait mais ça veut pas
dire que ça fait pas plus mal quand même
face à l'électorat comme le disait tout
à l'heure maicon les gens qui tout d'un
coup peuvent plus payer leur hypothèque
peuvent plus payer leur épicerie donc ça
même si il est pas nécessairement il
faut nécessaire de village et le petit
village auprès de cet électorat qui qui
souffrent en ce moment de factures qui
sont de puissance et la force mais je
croyais je trouve que d'aborder des
sujets extrêmement complexes comme
l'inflation l'économie le système
monétaire et d'aborder ce haut gradé mon
simple que le jatropha fois c'est
simpliste il fait des taux d'aidé des
raccourcis intellectuellement pas très
honnête mais ils vont chercher les
jaquettes même la question des peco
ailleurs il faut voir ses vidéos il rend
son intéressant on ne joue que l'écouté
c'est quand même un ton qui l'autorité
si j'étais libéral je m'inquiéterais
deux sacs cette course communicationnel
mais je suis pas en désaccord mais je
veux devenir un élément qui pour moi est
très important si jean charest n'avait
pas été dans cette course je me demande
ce monsieur poilievre aurait pris des
positions aussi large et aussi des
lycées fait tâche qu'on a vu de monsieur
soit lièvre 96 en aurait eu autant je
reviens à l'époque où harper a été élu
et représentez vous rappelez quand
madame ce trône à qui monsieur clément
s'était pas une opposition croque
monsieur parle peu avant de se présenter
comme candidat à la tête du parti unifié
sur des clips où il avait beaucoup plu
sujet controversé qui était associé avec
monsieur remis durant la campagne il
s'est gardé est resté très tranquille il
a été très discret sur des sujets
controversés et donc on n'a pas eu ce
genre d fait tort monsieur problème je
me demande s'il n'y a pas été faute et
par la présence de monsieur top de la
présence de monsieur charest et là ça se
demande ici lorsqu'il va revenir contre
monsieur trudeau en campagne électorale
est ce que le vieux voilier voir sortir
celui là qui est en tendance même si
comme une aiguille à sortir de sa zone
de confort mais sont en jeu suisse
aurait attendu à chaud le calcul autour
de poilievre qu'ils peuvent avec sursis
allait rapporter la prochaine élection
et font le pari que être trop perçu
comme états conservateurs
libéraux c'est pas bon ça fera que les
électeurs ont besoin d'un choix plus
clair là bas ce qui fait de s'assumer
ils sont 33 sélections peut-être mais on
est à la porte des buts alors à la porte
des buts je regarde la recette keith
bogans les 12 dernières verges c'est pas
une longue course au sol sur le marché
oui c'est que s'il pose ses sens
il ne fait pas non plus se contredire
complètement par rapport à ce qu'il a
déjà dit mais c'est ce qu'on a eu
tellement reproché à un automne au sein
du parti conservateur d'abord dit une
chose et son contraire de finalement
essayé de louvoyer dans un chemin
sinueux pendant la course précepteur à
tout le monde j'ai l'impression que
pierre poilievre a appris de ses erreurs
là aussi que vaut le vouloir est
beaucoup plus catégorique sur ses
positions mais en même temps c'est le
plus grand danger parce que ces
positions qu'il a prises pendant la
course certaines ont fait friser papier
qui vient aider des électeurs
excusez moi mais c'est son problème
c'est qu'il sait comme dirait un autre
passionné dans le coin à plusieurs
égards et moi je le vois pas détricoter
ce qu'il a pensé un instant son temps
marraine et hélène vous avez su ça
depuis le début cette force qui viennent
à va est-ce que vous avez quand même été
surprise par l'ampleur de la vague parce
que
les salles de jeu l'est de plus en plus
grands rennes réseaux sociaux et en
voyant pour cause très rapidement c'est
fait
fonctionner est notable c'est quand même
assez impressionnant dans une course de
voir s'étendre mans là tout à fait moi
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya quand même eu
un effet pandini là dedans de
frustration de gens qui étaient contre
les mesures sanitaires et qui avait
besoin de canaliser leur frustration
j'ai l'impression que de ça j'ai
l'impression qu'il y en a qui sont
vraiment années de ça que nous aussi
donc ils ont trouvé chez pierre
poilievre quelqu'un chez qui comptait
donc il réussi à canaliser une énergie
mais je me répète dans les sondages ça
bouge pas alors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire dans la population en général ça va
être son plus grand défi qu'elle se
livre à être qu'il va adopter je trouve
qu'on a quand même des belles questions
à se poser pour la suite la course ce
soir et les presque joué la suisse et ne
l'est pas encore non bien sûr que non
ainsi là c'est la grande angoisse des
conservateurs ne peuvent pas comme dit
michael ciotat ils sont à un pouce du
cirad fois là après trois mâts davide
rebellin grande angoisse je pense pour
moi ce soir sjps pas encore assez parce
que pour la première fois des pick up et
par 6 essais poilievre on a un chef on a
pas mal le meilleur chef depuis quand
répartis pour affronter
sage a su prouver mais ce n'est pas plié
malgré ce qu'il a dit surtout scorer
millions de billets dégâts sont mises
oui il ya des façons de s'en sortir on
trouve une candidate qui est excellente
en économie on est prudent sur ce qu'ont
déclaré
mais au-delà de ça je pense qu'ils vous
michael fortier le ch parle non pas un
analyste met aux conservateurs vous
seriez à l'aise de faire campagne avec
lui comme chef
je lui donnais je m'assois qui
s'expriment sur d'autres sujets
j'aimerais l'entendre à la suite de la
victoire ce soir si bien comment il va
traiter ses députés parce que moi
j'habite au québec sont par des gens
comme à l'air et s général d'intel sa
voiture d'essence on peut pas se
permettre ça et vous avez entièrement
raison je pense qu'on regarde beaucoup
l'ontario pour des gains pour le parti
conservateur mais vous avez raison de
dire on tue le québec pour être une
terre absolument très fertile pour le
parti conservateur
ne soit pas sans d alain réagi
desjardins et et talents made and i
failli de la colère et ce qui est ce que
j'ai été étonné d'apprendre de la force
2 septembre le oui je l'admets je ne
m'attendais pas une candidature aussi
puissante et effectivement il le surfer
sur cette colère sans limite où ce que
je me demande moi c'est dans trois ans
parce que l'élection pourrait même avoir
lieu que dans en 2025 à cause de ce
pacte avec le fbi qu'est ce qu'il
restera de cette colère est ce que ce
sera encore un motif suffisant pour
faire propulser pierre poilievre et le
faire dans les camps distincts credo
c'est ça la grande question
la recette de son succès aujourd'hui
sera t'elle vraiment la recette de sa
fusée man 3 le facteur vous éléphants
délit et concerne tout ce qu'on voit au
québec avec le parti conservateur c'est
un facteur important peut pas et
d'ailleurs les problèmes de poules ont
été cristallisée lors de manifestations
de camionneurs les fauves ne savait pas
comment ce que ce n'est pas ce convoi
était sur la clôture et il serait
demandé qu'on voit ça aurait été autre
chose ce n'est pas quelqu'un à aimer la
graine de leader on le vend autour non
non non le but c'est que dès qu'on voit
s'arrêter une grève dans les ports
société d'eau chance alors facile
manifester nommé pour moi je veux bien
vous avez raison dans trois ans on sait
pas ce qui va se passer mais poilievre a
selon moi des éléments de leadership qui
m'encourage pour
waziers j'ai failli signer je suive le
tempo d'être capable dé claude 1-3-1 de
maintenir la cadence il ne faut pas
s'ils vont quand même les suivre moi j'y
vais même en arrière de se rappeler vous
quand il était ministre des institutions
démocratiques et qu'il s'en était pris
au directeur général des élections qui
devaient et on voit très fort mais c'est
pas une bonne idée qu'est ce qui avait
induit au lion c'est vrai c'est juste
quelqu'un qui veut plus d'argent plus de
pouvoir voyons donc c'est la seule
personne au canada qui a pas le droit de
vote si le directeur général des
élections de quoi voir plus n'ont pas
accès aux mêmes sauts il ne l'a pas
respecté sa vont revenir bien là
l'essentiel 810 enquête ball un
personnage est adopté il est comme ça on
l'a donc voir s'il est capable de
s'élever s'appelait aux conservateurs
est-ce qu'ils vont réussir à 12 tirs les
angles petit peu pour plaire à un
électorat plus large on peut se poser la
question mais on est dans la continuité
à quand on s'attaque au directeur
général des élections
quand on s'attaque au gouverneur de la
banque du canada on sent un foyer qui
constat je veux dire est depuis toujours
n'a les soucis s'appuie là je vis moi je
me sens pas attaqué par pierre poilievre
0 mais ils aiment leur montrer qu'il
n'est pas avec elle il est vrai c'est
qu'il n'a pas eu besoin des médias pour
se faire suivre par des centaines de
milliers de personnes ce qui est un peu
vrai en soit dit en passant marqué il a
une force chez les médias sociaux qui
est impressionnante je mangeais pas jean
charest une parenthèse important que
chara au début elle saisit il a fait un
peu mais
ça c'est être habile et avoir un
membership aussi parce que quand la
course commençait la pierre poilievre
s'adressait des gens à un même bauchi
selon ces médias sociaux des 10 des gens
qui le suivaient des milliers de
personnes qui les suivaient jean charest
je pense qu'ils optent comme il aux
parties un compte twitter il s'était
inscrit sur twitter si je me souviens
bien au début de la course y avait pas
de profil oui donc ça c'est ça fait mal
en début de course je te nique vous
releviez parce que je vous ai posé comme
question sur l'environnement parce qu'il
y aura avec les libéraux un clash énorme
je faisais ils sont pas du tout à la
même enseigne à tuer ben on met en même
temps et la plage conservateur du graal
sur l'environnement et les lieux depuis
longtemps mais pas avec un porteur comme
poilievre qui osent aller au bout de la
logique là dessus peut-être mais je
pense que yonne un certain appétit pour
ce discours alternatif face à
l'environnement on le voit pas changé
quoi séduire
totalement différent quand même temps
que souvent les sondeurs nous dit c'est
que quand vous faites les électeurs ne
votent pas en fonction des questions
environnementales c'est très triste mais
semble-t-il que ce soit ce même jean
charest est en faveur des pipelines le
oui du rhin si vous regardez son
des policiers au albertaine qui voulait
changer la formule de péréquation pour
plus avantagés l'alberta alors monsieur
je suis charest avait en juste avait il
à on verra dans quelques minutes mais
c'est pas qu'il hommes en kaki
politiques pour tenter de celui de se
déplacer dans la région de monsieur de
monsieur poilievre même sort
pour le ce1 et on anticipe ça ne lui
aura pas permis de remporter la victoire
madeleine la droite européenne est
associé aux tours
identitaire
restreindre l'immigration
poilievre ces erreurs là dessus libero
aux amateurs sur l'immigration si la
même la même approche oui on n'a pas
joué là dessus du toucher le parti
conservateur maxime bernier lors de la
première élection je vois dernier lui
ait joué un petit peu là dessus retourne
un peu là dessus sur ce discours nage de
trous de réduire l'immigration canadair
ce que cette victoire de pierre
poilievre elle risque de faire d'abord
mal est d'abord mal à maxime bernier
parce qu'on est en train d'aller jouer
dans les mêmes talent ou talent un peu
plus à droite justement pro convoi mais
ce qui est intéressant avec caire foyer
c'est que il y aura pas trop de dettes à
l'endroit par exemple des conservateurs
sociaux y aura pas de dettes envers le
lobby des armes ya promis grand-chose à
des groupes non de lobby et sauf c'est
un avantage pour que malone et il a les
mains les bugs et christian noël avez
vous des nouvelles sur le déroulement
parce qu'on l'a on est à peu près à
l'heure dite
oui christian
cardon moi aussi j'veux qu'on entendit
la question je suis vraiment désolé
voilà non je devais avez vous des
nouvelles parce qu'on est à peu près à
l'heure dite donc ça ne ne devrait plus
tarder le lait les discours
protocolaires les remerciements s'est
terminée là
voilà on sent l'anticipation qui grandit
dans la salle cependant on souffle à
l'oreille qu'on n'a probablement entre 8
et 10 minutes de retard sur le programme
le programme était très serré on a loué
deux minutes pour une personne deux
minutes pour l'autre mais évidemment ça
prend toujours plus de temps et on
oublie de compter les applaudissements
donc le résultat qui devait sortir vers
7h33 pourrait prendre un autre dix
quinze minutes avant que le parti soit
prêt dans le programme à pouvoir
dévoiler des résultats
mais je fais très bien juste 15 minutes
c'est tout à fait normal merci et dès
que j'avais quelque chose christian
bougnon nous fait signe merci beaucoup
madame disait quelque chose
d'intéressant tout à l'heure quant à lui
parlé de maxime berreby et moi je ne
peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée
pour lui je me dis pauvre maxime s'il
avait attendu une course ou deux qui
aurait peut-être gagné quand on voit
l'état d'esprit des troupes
conservatrices qui se sont ralliés
derrière une candidature comme celle de
police qui je trouve n'est pas très
différent dans une approche à certains
égards je me suis beaucoup fait puis il
a presque gagné la predator ce tour où
il est arrivé 1 %
monsieur vers lui il aurait t shirt
rester encore chez rona sérieux mais il
après et poilievre a repris le bâton le
relais et cela même
élémentaire absolument oui absolument et
je pense que si maxime bernier avait été
chef du parti conservateur il y aurait
pu faire un tabac au québec je crois
après ça ici il s'est radicalisé à
certains égards il s'est discrédité à
plusieurs je dors sur la question sainte
terre et on en parle plus de la même
façon d'avoir
et je ne peux m'empêcher de voir que
il était au bon parti d'un ben saïd est
une erreur pour lui deux pas de claquer
après revenir michael fortier aucune
idée parce que c'est ce que metz que
poilievre intéresse qu il
connaît ma je ne sais pas si bernie
c'est quelqu'un qui aime l'attention sur
une personne qui aime est au centre des
choses alors s'il revenait dans le parti
conservateur il serait un parmi
plusieurs est ce que c'est quelque chose
qui l'intéresse je sais pas mais je vous
écoute je comprends ce que vous dites
mais bernier d'abord six s'étaient
présentés maintenant il y aurait eu à
affronter poilievre j'irai pas gagné
parce que bercy n'a pas cette profondeur
bernie il joue sur ce tome 2 ou 3
multiples ainsi fait de même à l'époque
j'ai travaillé avec lui c'est quelqu'un
qui qui avaient dit qu'ils étaient
capables de travailler quelques dossiers
mais pas trop mais il reviendra jamais
ils sont ils
conservateurs à
cause de l'immigration et monsieur
monsieur perdu justement ainsi parlé
d'immigration tout à l'heure et c'est
quand même la particularité de ce depuis
parti conservateur actuel c'est cette
façon de ne jamais remettre en question
les seuils d'immigration très élevé que
j'irai des libertés il ya une raison
pour cela c'est que à l'époque notamment
des tisanes kenny qui était le ministre
à vos cris en heureux rit celui qui
allait toujours dans les communautés
culturelles eh ben il a l'idée c'était
que il faisait les immigrants au canada
nous arrivent de pays
[Musique]
consommateurs comme le pakistan l'inde
et sert aussi des gens qui naturellement
devrait voter conservateur est donc en
fait une grande campagne de de
fait la cour à ces communautés là et il
ne pourrait pas aujourd'hui arriver
qu'un discours en disant ah on veut plus
d'immigration où on en veut moins et
c'est pour ce qu'ils sont par calcul
politique ils ne peuvent pas arriver
avec un discours alternatif mais moi je
pense qu'il y aura un appétit pour un
discours alternatif sollications à celui
des libéraux avec l'élection québec a
montré que
monsieur legault souhaiterait qu'il ya
une alternative au canada dans le reste
du canada pour que je n'étais pas sur le
l'abaissement des seuils sur le port
relatives à terme
non annoncé c'est un plaisir château
leader
[Applaudissements]
puisque cornet d'immigration attention
là parce que le plus grand cheval de
bataille de deux fortes en ce moment
c'est une augmentation de l'immigration
alors parti conservateur fédéral va pas
s'en aller
nous on s'en vont en sens inverse parce
que ça va devenir ils sont amis avec
françois legault très bonne presse sur
ces questions et on s'entend l'extérieur
du québec surtout à toronto et donc il
ya peut-être un appétit pour ce genre de
titres coureurs mais c'est pas une carte
maîtresse pour deux patients sur la
terre nord et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on
disait jusqu'avant vous arrive et on
dirait que avec les libéraux ils ont à
peu près les mêmes politiques face à
l'émigration
défenseurs matin
il faut se remettre ce qui est arrivé
par un campagne de stephen harper la
dernière fois où ils ont passé pour
avec leur ligne de dénonciation des
critiques alba ou y est on passé pour
des gens quitter en chimie qu'en ces
temps de
crise voyez les gens partir george et
moi mais comme les gens partir derrière
moi c'est une petite pause et après la
pause on nous a annoncé les résultats
dans très courte pause
sur le cieux d'humiliation je faire écho
ce que dit chantal c'est pas juste
d'être fort tous les chefs d'entreprise
qui moi je parle cherche
l'année
2000 gassion pas se projeter police il
c'est d'un bout à l'autre du pays les
gens ont besoin
d'employés qui regardent des vibrations
comme éteint allez débuter ce et c'était
l'enfance de patrick bras on a en en os
x par année beaucoup mais c'était dans
les communautés culturelles que patrick
brown essayé de recruter des membres et
il en a recruté probablement quelques
milliers et finalement en étant
talbot a encore parce qu'il était encore
là mais sorti de la course probablement
suis d'accord avec vous que michael que
ce probablement que des électeurs qui
ont décidé de ne pas aller voter parce
que patrick grand détective oui mais la
dernière fois qu'ils avaient nourri
donné son appui à maxime bernier sucer
vote était allé à maxime bernier les
gens qui avaient signé pour voter pour
lui avec ce merveilleux gagnant deux
tours de scrutin
pour cent mais les gens qui avaient
[Musique]
nourri s'emparer
c'est assez compliqué 21 photocopier sa
carte
sa carte d'identité
d'ailleurs chez quand poilievre qui
était quand même assez organisés et se
sont acheté des photocopieurs
pour pouvoir faciliter l'envoi des
bulletins de vote parce que tout le
monde qu'une photo passer leurs lots je
trouve j'aimerais sur les en donnant les
espaces conservateur souvent remis en
question le vote par correspondance lors
des élections générales qui est
exactement sur le prochain débat c'est
vrai
je veux revoir si on peut mettre le
tableau 2
les gens qui regardent se disent
michael forcillo dit tout à l'heure si
jean charest n'était pas allait
s'arrêter une course quand même presque
anonyme oui le loup et c'est arrivé
troisième et c'est pas des gens qui ont
une grande notoriété on va dire ça comme
ça
pourquoi question 5 mai
c'est quand même une course la personne
qui gagne c'est pour cela a des chances
de devenir première amy est pourquoi les
gens avec plus de notoriété de tirades
haut niveau ont plu ma porte est une
fausse impression
parce que c'est votre définition de
si l'un d'eux
est ce que c'est une personnalité
d'affaires une personnalité du monde du
milieu culturel moi je regarde les
courses au leadership de tous les partis
confondus il ya beaucoup de chiens qui
sont connues mais c'est le code ils sont
pas de qualité donc le protocole parti
conservateur cette fois-ci attirer des
gens intéressants déjà la da pour qu'ils
mangeraient pas voté au premier tour
mais c'est quand même il ya pour moins
de tuer un bon soin de jacky de tous les
horizons
si plus serein là
on ne m'a
jamais plu à la fin mais qui se fait non
emmanuelle devos promis pour mais
qu'est-ce qui se fout questions moins
qu'un athlète marocain nice présente le
monde s'y retrouve et que c'est vraiment
une belle course très franchement non
les fonds souverains toute bonne foi
wyclef jean qui a été premier ministre
et qui a eu des responsabilités
ministérielles qui a été chef dans
l'opposition est quelqu'un qui a été
miné associer les gens le profil des
candidats qui aspirent à être premier
ministre c'est le cas de monsieur paul
young
devrait apporter un certain bagage
d'expérience police et les jo c'est
digne aux détenus comme un aveu il a été
exclu par doc folle parce que il ya fait
toute sa campagne et in the blade il
connaît même pas le début d'une
poussière de la politique fédérale pizza
dynamique canadienne pour les
assimiler cela nous est expliqué dans
une entrevue récemment que autres une
des choses sont parties nos brillants
des censeurs dans les épiceries pour
empêcher les gens ne rient de la crème
glacée si on mangeait du sucre en vo par
lille contre huawei situations de
racisme ou pas oui mais la dépression
c'est la question je pensais que c'était
pourquoi on n'est pas capable d'être
solide mon arrivée la veille moi je suis
en plus exprimé j'ai croisé vous avez
qui osera grard qualitatif sur les gens
qui étaient là parce que j'avais dit oui
dans les réseaux
comme il ya des faits comme
madame le plus que tout le monde ici
ensemble sur le tapis sur le plateau
ensemble sans talons qui donc est pas
bonne parce que je n'ai pas à titre
personnel ce que tu as programme on
mange la grande on peut envisager une
fête on tient de réponse on est dans la
troisième course en cinq ans la première
course on a quand même vu des 32 normes
on en a quand même eu des liserés par
exemple dans la deuxième course on ait
eu des piqûres mais qu'est ces gens là
ont tenté leur chance voilà ils vont pas
nécessairement recommencer alors surtout
lorsqu'ils ont vu le sort réservé aux
prédécesseurs on ne peut pas vraiment
deuxième chance dans ce parti
toc et
monsieur s'est fait montrer la porte
de façon peut-être un peu plus politique
aernoudt houleux mais il a dû partir et
renault tout s'est fait montrer la porte
même s'il avait remporté le vote
populaire donc on est dans une dynamique
et très très difficile et c'est pas
nécessairement des gens de grande grande
qualité qui vont vouloir tenter cette
expérience parce que c'est cruel c'est
faire le lit des gosses la mine au
panache d'eau était
on se disait vraiment ce qu'on assiste à
un débat pour la personne qui va devenir
premier ministre du canada
et ça c'est en toute objectivité
regarder ça sert ohlala
avez vous vu le premier 2 moi j'ai vu le
débat au québec à laval et j'étais
découragé pause imaginer oui non mais un
problème de communication en français
mais
gigean se sont pas présentés parce que
d'abord pour liège déjà parent s'est
produit à valeur à la garnison parlement
eu raison donc beaucoup de jeux qui sont
pas allés à cause de paul hier mais moi
j'ai un problème quand des gens décident
quand tu es jeune tu es candidat au
leadership donc fin du match nice 1 0
mais je n'ai jamais dit que des bonnes
choses au clair photo et courent ainsi
qu à l'eau qu'est ce qui fait l'homme
peut-il imaginer on l'a fait
parce que je suis quand même pas mal élu
il y avait 15 ans nous n'allons mais
avec un grand quand même tu avais jamais
mis les pieds dans une assemblée pour te
faire choisir comme candidat bonne
partie s'était jamais mis sur les rangs
pour le recruter et on parlera pose de
ce que ça donne me conseiller
mais c'est pas grave non mais oui déjà
les amoureux par réal un parfait inconnu
qui avait aucun aucun de feuilleton est
inverse non mais c'est faux jugements
j'étais à ces gens par le parti shard
avaient cessé ce n'est pas ce qu'on
foute jugement qualitatif sur jack sur
l'eau et je pense que c'est quand même
mais c'est normand jean rampon
c'est à dire qu'à contrario parce qu'il
ya pas de pompe sans et entend ce
concours de réponse qu'on est déjà
mouillé connu dans une [ __ ] évident
à
98,11 étiez seul un bravo d'après vous
avez continué mais que quatre sur six
soit totalement est connu à peu près de
tous les canadiens six équipes en armes
le web qui sont partis c'est un grand
parti qu'est l'histoire où on se dit
alors peut-être poilievre est
effectivement trop fort trop fort mais
j'ai commencé à dire heureusement que
jean charest tally sinon la demi
mesure
ribéry n'a jamais
deux ans comme vérité pour apprendre le
français ce qu'elle n'a pas fait l es
deux ans pour démontrer qu'elle avait
de quelqu'un que le devenir premier
ministre
ici amérique est devenu anti vaccins et
qu'elle a expliqué dans ce cas pas
docteur en médecine et docteur de dr
elle explique aux gens que c'était une
très mauvaise dit à vacciner leurs
enfants et ados notre studio de monsieur
ben harper je le répète a aucune
connaissance des dynamiques canadienne
et id aspire à être premier ministre à
un moment donné on peut pas dire ces
gens là sont des gens intéressants et
c'est pas gentil digues sont pas
qualifiés ils ne sont pas deux des trois
qui est monsieur ericsson qui est député
chose c'est le plus c'est dit
parce que sa campagne est écrit à
monsieur wang quitter l'om et patrick
brown c'est fascinant parce que nous on
le couvert à ottawa c'est à dire le
couvert on l'a découvert parce que l'on
était député à ottawa une décennie pour
sauver mais on sait qu'ils causent à
répondre qu'à turin aussi lâchement
ontarienne on savait pas du tout et qui
selon d'après n'est qu'elle est restée
députée fédérale tout en sollicitant la
chefferie ontarienne qui ont échappé
d'un corridor technique je n'ai à des
mois jean charles est pourquoi
il m'a appuyé comme juste dans ses choix
on va aller voir
christian vous avez des nouvelles offres
christian
bon bah on lira plus tard s'il m'entend
pas
oui voilà donc on n'a pas là on apprend
que m granger dans la série bien sûr
voilà
[Musique]
non devra maintenant que les résultats
très abîmé
je situe à dans une salle qu'il est
sécurisé et
encore de chaque candidat sont en train
de vérifier si les résultats sont
vraiment ceux auxquels ils ont assisté
alors qu'il faisait la tabulation des
résultats pour cette semaine lors de
cette dernière vérification elle a lieu
maintenant en compagnie notamment de la
crème des vérifications de loi qui était
retenu par le parti conservateur pour ça
sage on ne dit pas ses résultats
ils seront transportés de cette salle
sécurisée
alhassane condé
il
est-ce que des caméras sur l'équipe de
monsieur charest monsieur charest
monsieur poilievre j'aimerais voir
les réactions lorsqu'on dire ces
chiffres là on faisait des blagues mais
c'est tout à fait serrer vous avez fait
de course et les cantons se lance dans
une course monsieur charest au départ
c'est pas l'un c'est pour perdre sinon
il il fallait qu'il y croit quand même
saleh qu'il croit
il ya une salle est promené ses three
beaucoup de sections avec sa famille il
ya tout laisser on a parlé tantôt c'est
quand même quelqu'un qui a une vie
professionnelle très active des sondés
conseil d'administration you tous les
mythes côté s'en prenait aucune j'en
suis convaincue de tout pouvoir
retrouver
pour ça parce qu'il voulait être premier
ministre canada
et donc s'il perd ce soir je vous ai le
même si fire 51 49 à la maxime bernier
un douchez ou qu'ils perdent 68 à terme
c'est une grosse déception pour lui ce
qu'ont vécu et il va garder désert aucun
sympathie qui voit revenir son plateau
ici va sourire et pour lui il va y avoir
des blessures j'en suis convaincu qu'ils
ont deux tables as-tu c'était ça faisait
partie de ses rêves de ses objectifs il
est allé au bout mais
on le voit là
c'est
c'est ça reste dur pour être sacré j en
fais quand vous avez quand même été
premier ministre du québec de revenir
comme ça de d'offrir ses services pour
le premier ministre canadien et qui se
faire montrer d'abord dire on n'en veut
pas c'est vrai tu sais les stater avec
un coquet que soit le résultat ça va
être sélectionné
[Musique]
je me suis la dernière course
le chien c'est roger béquilles
c'est quand même un des plus grands
talents de sa génération c'est encore
vrai mais il aucun parti
[Musique]
moi je suis de l'école pensent que jean
charrier ya trouvé son compte sans égard
aux résultats et je suis de toute façon
totalement anecdotique parce que j'ai
remarqué comment les gens qui se parlent
les électeurs non montant de jean
charest m 1 par rapport à comment il
fallait trancher avant la course il
entend pas de la même façon c'est devenu
leur joie dans une course plutôt que
premier ministre est parti du tas qui le
machin est exact le discours nature a
vraiment changé depuis et nous sommes de
rédemption de saint cadou qu'il a dit
est aussi
gelé entendu de gens proches de lui qui
m'ont dit passez moi l'expression
anglaise et wenwen c'est que même si on
perd il a aussi refait d'une certaine
façon de virginie
il a refait tous ses contacts au canada
et si je fais une entrevue que jean
charest dans ce domaine tout à l'heure
où dans quatre semaines première
question ce sera pas la commission
charbonneau
il avait fait ton parti ouais mais non
mais ce que j'avais des boulets que qui
trouvaient peut-être plus de jeu que
d'autres attraits
et d'un point de vue humain le regret
c'est terrible pour quelqu'un qui avait
un rêve de vouloir devenir premier
ministre et ceux d'hier vont peut-être
que je lis raté ma chance c'est terrible
ils veulent avoir tenté sa chance il va
avoir été au bout de l'exercice et oui
c'est dur d'échouer à la ligne d'arrivée
mais en même temps si je pense que c'est
pire de se dire et si j'avais et si
j'avais tenté ma chance je pense que
l'exercice il est probablement positif
dessus de ce que je suis en moins de
gens vont le résultat mais selon son
niveau des tuyaux aux relents même
d'auge d'humiliation latin je pense pour
un ancien communiste composent ce que
vous dites par rapport à se refaire une
virginité mais pensons à monsieur
deltell par exemple qui avait dit t il
eu des mots très durs pour monsieur
charest il ya beaucoup de banques qui
ont ravalé x se sont rangés à lui
simplement parce qu'il ne voulait pas de
monsieur qu'il faut lire pas
nécessairement parce qu'ils avaient
d'emblée
passion pour le char et y en avait quand
même beaucoup qui ont fait ça de manière
rationnelle ce ralliement là il n'y pas
pour ce qu'il incarne en ce qu'il
proposait comme vision de la politique
mais ils sont paumés contente sa
campagne parce que ça c'est l'autre
chose c'est une longue campagne en plus
des sonneries en campagne même quand on
était plus à la politique quand les gens
vont écrire sociale qu'un bain ici et on
peut
écrire jean charest talent campagne
has been qui a fait une campagne
vraiment et elle est très lisse vidéo ça
leur peau et s'ils gagnaient jusqu'à il
aura pas d'henri libéraux en mode qui
est passé d oeil
on n'a pas donné ainsi que capois diable
donner localement dans les rayons
d'éviter la tête mais gestion avoue
chantal parce que vous le connaissez
très bien pensez vous que s'il savait
s'il avait su à l'époque qu'il allait
faire comme il allait faire
pensez vous qu'il est allé moi non
michael je pense qu'il y allait pour
gagner patrice est joué vous et moi je
pense qu'elle verrait il n'y avait pas
de wayne il voulait gagner michael la
dernière fois ce thème de automne c'est
d'ailleurs j'ai parlé souvent avec jean
charest et il est vraiment se présenter
je fais pas partie des gens qui l'ont
encouragé et je me souviens de ce que je
suis
cette fois ci mon parti il m'a appelé
parce qu'il y allait y aller de toute
façon
garnier qui devrait empêcher madian la
raison leurs griefs
le boulet port c'est une tentation à
laquelle
il ya les amis veste et essuie un espoir
s'est embarqué là-dedans les yeux permis
d appréhension et moi poilievre salle
est monté à ce point qui allait avoir
une le souhait de la victoire il est
très très très étroit oui passer par le
québec il passait par l'atlantique il
passe par une partie l'ontario mais
effectivement il ya eu une vague je
parle d'un rouleau compresseur de pierre
poyet qui finit effectivement ils nous
ont pris les autres aussi en sept ans d
pas assis foule l'a donc et jean charest
sont maintenant parce que j'ai bien de
voir si les mots que vous employez
monsieur poêlier pour parler de ce char
elle vraiment les mots exacts
si votre routeur ou pas est-ce qu'ils
vont s'élever ou quoi c'est sûr qu'il va
sceller ce soir des oui moi j'ai
vraiment surpris si on n'entendait pas
des mots
chaleureux à son à son égard parce que
charest dans le cpom et cède 1 2 3 ans
pour des élections si poyet devient pas
unie du canada charette pourrait faire
taxicos de son métier puisque andré pas
pour lui mais pourrait certainement et
dans le sage autour de lui ils nous ont
été soignées ou essaient de poilievre
jeu
je ne serai pas cette chance là me filer
entre les doigts donc je sais tout mais
pas ce soir pas demain parce que les
blessures vont être trop vive mais le
détail ont des amis en commun déjà
qu'ils peuvent établir sein d'un convoi
celui qui s'achemine et tout indique que
ce sera une grande victoire monsieur
poilievre qui
[Musique]
je vois donc livré peut-être un de ses
discours les plus importants dans le col
et au tour il était deux heures du matin
personne n'écoute dans le cas de poil
hier compte tenu de la lure de la
campagne c'est peut-être un des discours
le plus important sur les prochains mois
de ce parti là à ce que le parti voir
réussir
les prêts à garder vous avez dit michael
fortier perdez deltell et des rays au
québec serait pas une bonne nouvelle
alors peu importe la force
de poilievre que pour les réinventer ces
gens 2,6 jamais alors et
là aussi le corridor est étroit
madeleine partis du vent parce que on a
parlé de l'importance du québec mais
comme bâtir au québec faut quand même
bâtir sont des acquis ici on pour les
acquis que sont effectivement reyes
joël hugonnet on n'en a pas parlé
beaucoup mais c'est lui qui a été le
plus dur en menant qui se retrouveraient
pas nécessairement dans un parti sous
pierre poilievre mais on commence avec
un difficile finalement
les conservateurs ont montré qu'ils
étaient capables de gagner cent au
québec c'est possible
c'est quand même c'est quand même se
donner des soins qui est quand même plus
compliqué
constater que carrefour était élu chef
de temps ci il était contre linda strana
qui avait un appui massif d'une partie
du parti qui était associé à la branche
progressiste conservateur
tonique l'amène c'est un peu un être
hybride et on avait pris pied à l'époque
il y allait avoir une rue fractures
internes accord je veux pas mettre des
lunettes roses mais je pense que ça peut
se ressoude bien sûr parce que cela
touche des éléments tu veux je gagne
parce que je l'aï vu avec un peu
évidemment la campagne avec l'onac et
plaine n'a pas été aussi mesquine
celle-ci stéphane ap moi je recevais des
courriels des porte voix de monsieur
poilievre qu'ils ont attaqué
monsieur charest nommé main
de façon honteuse de ledit honteuse et
me suis polie elle devrait avoir honte
d'avoir laisser ces gens là parler en
son nom dont ses responsables et pour
cette chasse est passé lui qui dirige le
prince et jallet sont en forme et sont
encore des porte voix à d'autres égards
c'est un risque en cours comme partie
mobilité j'espèrerais de points de vue à
pousser qu ai-je donc on surfait à mon
avis
la réunification du parti avec monsieur
un peu moi je trouve pas que se passe
t-il aussi entièrement
aussi dès ce parti-là ici réforme usé
beaucoup avait pas un peu et qui parce
qu'il aura apporté de pouvoirs je
demande un complice ont pu lire cette
question mais je n'ai jamais senti que
depuis la fusion fait partie des 16 m
kiko et rage sans encore des ailes qui
ne sont pas nécessairement d'une
coalition la cac il ya des gens très
fédéraliste à la cac et ça commence un
peu au parti mais ça prend chef
d'orchestre c'est un peu seul mais ça
prend quelqu'un qui justement capable de
s'intéresser à tout le monde de manière
à faire des compromis at heart attendait
mais et monsieur poilievre ne mesure pas
de monter cette capacité identique annie
parent c'est quand on regarde ses
projections finalement se rassemble
cherchez chamakh de remporter l'élection
moi je pense que les clubs veulent la
solution être chef de l'opposition cpl
est premier ministre a lui été moins
parce que les gens ont l'air d'oublier
c'est malgré cette semaine au sein du
portugal avant que justin trudeau
gagnant de 15 les anciens idéaux le
bronze toronto ce soit et dans toutes
les oreilles eric b retrouver combien
justin trudeau et
conseils et l'entouré un crack music
défaut aurait pas des sénateurs et à qui
en avait si vous n'êtes plus dans le
caucus je veux juste revenir sur
l'équation de monsieur trois lièvres au
québec il ya une donnée supplémentaire
compliquer la donne à l'aise on a parlé
un tout petit caux et c'est la proximité
en pierre poilievre
et là
il le parti conservateur du québec
est-ce que c'est l'allié du de pierre
poilievre moi je pense qu'une partie de
recrutement québec de 4e les nouveaux
mobiles e-bay liste c'est beaucoup trop
cher mais c'est pas tous les députés du
québec sont confortables avec l'idée que
plutôt que de s'aligner sur l'a4 oui 50
ans dames je vais aller où on s'aligne
ce éric duhaime et sans parti et ça ça
joue quant à l'inflation elle me demande
dans ma circonscription pourquoi je sois
pas campagne pour est actuelle ce n'est
que le début de cette année resserré sur
leurs skis après les requins la voilà
l'heure de vérité mesdames et messieurs
on aura les chiffres temps quelques
secondes je vous rappelle le premier qui
dépasse 50% des points c'est 100 points
par circonscription gagne cette course
au leadership
alors c'est un pourcentage que vous
allez recevoir
les chiffres
beaucoup de gens
prési un premier tour voilà ce qu'on
verra si ça se confirme nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs
des résultats elles sont mortes
[Applaudissements]
nous avons un nouveau chef
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et trois ans
ces messieurs me pierre
avec
68% des
sa botte tout ce qui avait été fait
comme cours chalet chef de ce parti aux
mêmes
la plupart des courses et la cheville
[Applaudissements]
68% des voix qui ramasse
tout le paquet dans toutes les provinces
ce qui veut dire que
les nouveaux membres au canada c'était
des mains poilievre et voilà la preuve
il a 40 3 1 et dès demain matin il va
regarder sa prochaine bataille
avec les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jaffe une campagne extrêmement agressive
que maintenant on
s'il avait besoin il armait trop tard
mais c'est le seul choix liège
cette ball en battant
[Applaudissements]
commun
ce que l'on ya effectivement des
des mains attendre
monsieur charest
ray c'est 2%
c'est moins un siècle pour ça
[Musique]
ce qui est peu
[Applaudissements]
on va les écouter
m
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
avant de vous présenter mon mari
permettez moi de présenter enfin de
partager avec vous ma tristesse
suite à la mort de la reine
alors mon mari et moi partageons les
mêmes valeurs
même si notre espérance de quelque peu
différent
à caracas au venezuela et ma famille a
émigré au canada en 1985 nous dans à
l'est de montréal hochelaga-maisonneuve
et pointent d'autres
et ma famille émigrée ici en 1995 à
montréal tu as un quartier de chez les
gunners et puis pointe un train
entre moorea latine elle remplace l nous
ne vous en tant que femmes latino avec
grand honneur que je représente en fait
le peuple migrants et de nombreux et
venezuela et de nombreux immigrants
[Applaudissements]
myfab
mon père en fait je re est une banque et
puis finalement il a sauté dans un
camion il a ramassé des fruits et des
légumes pour pouvoir nourrir sa famille
est passé de porter des complets et à
gérer une banque en monté à l'arrière
d'une camionnette avec des vêtements
usagés afin de ramasser des fruits des
légumes dans les champs car c'est ce
qu'il devait faire pour nourrir notre
famille
est une famille
donc il n'y a pas plus de grande dignité
que de pouvoir nourrir votre propre
famille
la famille gallineau
enfin il doit présenter ce soir
il a enseigné qu'il faut travailler fort
et qui n'a pas plus grande dignité que
de souvenirs aux besoins de votre
famille
oui nous voici dix années plus tard
mon père est un petit entrepreneur et
mes frères et soeurs sont passés de
l'immunité moi même je commence à
travailler au mcdonald's et je suis une
maîtrise je suis infirmière il ya aussi
un membre des forces armées très fier et
me voici ici
ma race face à vous et aux côtés de mon
mari
vient me viennent colorer mebina
mondiaux qu'est-ce qui aurait pu
imaginer
l'histoire de mon mari est un peu
différente il est né à calgary
d'une mère adolescente qui venait juste
de perdre assure sa mère donc elle a
donné son enfant en adoption à deux
fantastiques professeurs de la région
ils sont ici aussi ce soir
l'histoire de mon mari est un peu
différente il est né à calgary d'une
mère adolescente qui venait tout juste
de perdre sa propre mère est la dernière
à l'adoption de merveilleux professeurs
d'école élémentaire provenant de la
saskatchewan et ils sont présents ici ce
soir
sow
[Applaudissements]
donc nous avons tous grandi de la même
façon nos familles en fait passer d'un
chacun le tout en sachant qu en fait
remplir le réservoir d'essence n'est pas
un luxe mais vous permet de vous rendre
à votre travail est d'amener vos enfants
à l'école
donc nous avons grandi très
similairement ne familles vivent
toujours en attendant le prochain chèque
de paie en sachant que faire le plein
d'essence n'est pas un luxe mais un
moyen de transport pour aller travailler
ou amener aux enfants à l'école soleil
gentlemen alors mesdames et messieurs
un magnifique au père un mari
adorable un fils très respectueux rewi
très respectueux oui
c'est le nouveau chef du parti
conservateur du canada
mon mari pierre poilievre
merci mon corps
merci à noida je t'aime
à big n 1 bis laissez-moi commencé par
dire pas représenté en fait ma tristesse
suite au décès de notre reine adoré 2 me
très simple la reine et cela dit sur
chaque continent ces deux mots en fête
donne beaucoup plus qu'une image
elektrim également une idée l'idée de la
décence du devoir
elizabeth 2
même si en fait n'était pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ça en fait c'était la
femme la plus connue oui c'était notre
reine notre souveraine pendant
pratiquement la moitié de l'existence de
notre pays dans le cadre des deux 22
visite oui dans le cas de ces deux
visites et faisons face à face avec le
nombreux en fête premier ministre elle a
fait preuve de dignité de sens civil de
candeur et surtout
du sens du devoir voilà pourquoi son
décès même s'il n'était pas inattendu
néanmoins choquant nous pensions que
nous la connaissions nous pensions que
ses forces étaient les nôtres la force
d'un pays qui est heureusement pas la
grâce de dieu nous appelons jeu notre
chez nous notre pays
[Applaudissements]
et c'est peut-être pour cette raison que
je sens en fait un petit chat dans ma
gorge quand je prononce des mourgues
aucun leader n'a prononcé depuis plus de
70 ans ici
que dieu sauve le roi
préserve le roi
chennai
ce soir c'est le début d'un long chemin
pour remplacer un ancien gouvernement
qui dépense plus et qui donne moins et
qu'ils ne devaient vraiment mettre de
l'avant vote vos chèques vos logements
votre travail votre pays
[Applaudissements]
en
nous attaquant contre l'inflation de
libéraux nous vous remettre redonneront
le contrôle sur votre vie le travail
commence ce soir pour remplacer ce vieux
gouvernement qui me coûte plus cher et
que vous apporte moins avec un nouveau
gouvernement qui vous place en premier
votre chèque de paie votre retraite
votre maison votre pays
à nous attaquons à l'inflation
nous vous rendrons le contrôle de votre
argent et de votre vie est mise à bord
you
et c'est vous qui est important ce n'est
pas ma victoire mais la voûte je dois
remercier énormément de monde
et qui se sont portés volontaires pour
cette victoire merci aux autres
candidats d'avoir renouvelé notre parti
5 ue
merci à scott mais qui sommes de pouvoir
proposer des idées comme simplifier et
baisser les impôts merci énormément
scott
[Applaudissements]
merci
d'avoir voulu défendre et faire des
proposé de faire des sacrifices pour la
liberté de tout le monde
et merci
merci elles sont partout sa partenaire
non ici qui défend les intérêts des
enfants autistes merci
merci à lake louise d'avoir défendu la
famille la liberté
et la foi
et à son mari de l'avoir supporter tout
soutenu tout au long et merci
merci à jean charest du service que vous
avez apporté à notre pays
[Applaudissements]
et de vous être assurés que nous avons
toujours un pays uni et que nous
appelons notre chez-nous merci d'avoir
lutté pour le canada jean même si en
1995 dans le cadre du référendum et bien
ce n'était pas mieux vous avez défendu
avec votre passion notre poisson et nous
vous en seront pour toujours très
reconnaissant
ça fait à peu près 40 ans que j'en ai
tant politiques aux niveaux provincial
et fédéral et c'est dur mais souvent les
vrais héros c'est pas les candidats
c'est leur famille
voilà pourquoi je tiens à remercier
michel dessous quarante dernières années
il ya eu de nombreuses occasions où son
mari a lutté pour des causes en notre
nom à tous et à toutes lorsque vous avez
dû en fait faire davantage de sacrifices
de ses sacrifices invisible et nous en
tant que pays et en tant que parti nous
vous remercions merci michel
je prends le ses bras à tous les partis
dans j'ouvre mes bras pour tous
aujourd'hui nous sommes un seul parti
qui va servir un seul pays
c'est
encore plus important merci à ma femme
brillante
pour avoir été mauvais mon pilier tout
au long de cette folle aventure
sur rendu cela possible tu es ma
meilleure amie est l'amour de ma vie
oui
[Applaudissements]
à la famille d'anna ida qui a pris soin
de nos enfants lorsque nous étions sur
la route vous avez rendu cela possible
muchas gracias a la famille et bim
merci beaucoup à la famille de ma femme
et de leur contribution au canada
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est tout l'espagnol que je parle
si jamais vous venez nous voir chez nous
pour un rassemblement en famille en
général il ya une vingtaine de latinos
et latine en fait qui raconte des
histoires des blagues en espagnol est un
une seule personne qui absolument aucune
idée de ce que les autres sont en train
de se dire
la famille de ma femme non seulement à
éduquer cette femme fantastique mais
sont venus du venezuela avec
pratiquement rien et depuis lors cette
famille entrepris a commencé des
commerces à et
éduquer des enfants est bâti notre pays
et je tiens à remercier mon frère
patrick mon père donne son épouse masse
partenaire également ma mère biologique
jacky est ici aujourd'hui avec nous
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes une famille vraiment très
diversifiés comme notre pays je tiens à
remercier donc mes parents en
particulier je tiens à remercier mes
parents et mes deux professeurs en fait
qui m'ont éduquée qui m'ont dit que peu
importe d'où je venais mais ce qui était
important c'est où j'allais pas ce que
je savais mais ce que je pouvais faire
c'est de l'espoir que je veux
transmettre à mes enfants
[Applaudissements]
l'espoir en fait c'est transformé en
préoccupation pour beaucoup d'entre nous
aujourd'hui les gens ont le sentiment
d'avoir perdu le contrôle de leur argent
et de leur vie parce que le gouvernement
fait augmente le coût de la vie ce
gouvernement
libéral a
multiplié notre déficits et notre dette
il a ajouté beaucoup plus à la dette que
tous les autres mamans antérieur cela
veut dire plus de un demi million de
dollars qui s'ajoutent explique pourquoi
on paye davantage d'impôts
et l'inflation est énorme aujourd'hui
ils vont muter par trois en fait la taxe
sur le carbone sur le chauffage et
beaucoup d'autres choses
de la vie ce gouvernement a ajouté un
autre des nationales plus que tous les
autres gouvernements dans l'histoire de
notre pays ça veut dire 500 milliards de
dollars qui ajoute à l'inflation et aux
augmentations des taux d'intérêt c'est
le gouvernement le plus cher dans notre
histoire
c'est le gouvernement le plus cher de
toute l'histoire et plus il dépensa plus
les choses nous coûte cher en résultats
et bien les familles en fête diminue
leur régime alimentaire pour vous faire
face à l'augmentation de 10% par an les
personnes âgées en fait reporte le
retraité regardent leurs épargnes
s'évaporer en raison de l'inflation les
jeunes de 30 ans qui ont tous fait qu'on
de ce qu'on leur a demandé en fait
reporte
l'achat il se trouve en fait dans des
petits logements parce que le prix des
logements a été multiplié par deux son
gouvernement
et les personnes propriétaires payent
davantage d'intérêt sur leur hypothèque
même si ce gouvernement approché promis
que en fait ils n'augmenteront pas
l'étude de terrain
pour pouvoir se permettre la hausse de
10 % de la nourriture d'une allée un
autre les personnes âgées
ou alors d'économiser m'apparaît avec
l'inflation des jeunes de 30 ans qui ont
fait tout ce que nous avons demandé de
obtenir un diplôme travailler pour vivre
dans le sous sol de leurs parents parce
que les prix des maisons ont doublé et
ceux qui ont une maison paie davantage
d'intérêt pour leur hypothèque
voilà pourquoi les gens sont inquiets
certains ont la chance de pouvoir vivre
mais d'autres se retrouvent deux côtés
il ya des gens dans ce pays en fait
qui vivent sur un fil ce sont des
citoyens de notre pays
nous en fait devons les servir nous leur
devons l'espagne n'ont pas besoin d'un
gouvernement en fait qui les traitent de
mauvaise passe on n'a pas besoin de
gouvernement qui gèrent leur vie mais
nous avons besoin d'un gouvernement qui
s'occupe des bureaux de passeport
[Applaudissements]
nous allons en fait en sorte que la vie
soit à nouveau abordables nous allons
plafonner les dépenses pour des pour
diminuer en fait les uns pour
l'inflation selon y compris en fait
diminuer les taxes sur le chauffage
l'essence etc
cela signifie lutter contre le
changement climatique grâce à la
technologie et non aux impôts
dimanche nous allons restaurer l'espoir
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
si une mère monoparentale avec trois
enfants qui gagne quoi 50000 part j'en
fais tu gagnes un autre dollars elle va
perdre 75 centimes autour les impôts
dont elle n'arrive pas à aller de
l'avant je vais informer les programmes
réduire les impôts afin que cette mère
monoparentale les autres personnes comme
elle gagne + concert plus et que le
travail acharné soit payant dans ce pays
nous redonnerons de l'espoir que le
travail devient
mais en réduisant les impôts pas que les
gens qui gardent l'argent qu'ils gagnent
pour leur famille plutôt que de tout
perdre au gouvernement et ses crimes au
cash donc au lieu de créer davantage
d'argent d'espacé bien pensez-y si vous
avez dit un morceau de pain et 10
dollars bon bah c'est une tranche de
pain un dollar si vous multipliez le
nombre de dollars par deux et vous avez
toujours une tranchée pas chaque tranche
coûte de dollars vous savez dépenser
davantage ne donne pas plus nous avons
besoin de gagner plus alors au lieu de
multiplier les fonds multiplions les
tranches de pain
éliminons en fait les gardiens du
gouvernement pour
produire davantage d'énergie ici même au
canada et produire davantage de
logements
nous devons ré de redonner de l'espoir
pour les propriétaires aujourd'hui les
jeunes ne peuvent pas acheter en fait
parce que les tons sont très élevés
il y avait beaucoup moins de logements
par habitant que partout dans d'autre
part comparativement à d'autres pays
même si on a en fait davantage de
territoire donc les on a besoin en fait
de fonds pour diminuer les prix pourrait
approuver en fait la construction de
logements abordables de façon que nos
jeunes puissent sauter vivent n'est pas
besoin en fait de se demander si vous ne
pourrez acheter une voiture
on va aussi en fait
transformé 15 % des édifices du
gouvernement pour en faire des logements
autrement dit arrêté d'imprimer de
l'argent de construire commencé à
construire des logements pour notre
population
et à propos de logements toujours nous
devons en fait
aider les gens et faire en sorte que les
gens soit ici au canada vous savez les
échanges c'est très bien mais nous avons
appris pendant la
la coved qu'on ne peut pas compter sur
le reste du monde donc voilà pourquoi on
doit être le meilleur endroit pour les
employés les commerces étaient pour que
des entreprises soient construites qu'on
exploite en fait d'autres ressources
aujourd'hui on perd des salaires parce
qu'on importe 130 en fait millions de
barils provenant de dictature au
quotidien même si on a en fait
énormément de pétrole disponible ici au
canada et le gouvernement en fait tu
préfères le pétrole de mauvais dictature
pour pouvoir financer l'énergie du
canada
mais nous nous avons abrogé en fait les
lois du gouvernement en matière
d'environnement et nous allons protéger
l'événement tout d'abord consulter les
premières nations et faire les choses
qui s'imposent
nous allons en fait
améliorer leurs augmenter la production
de pétrole pour remplacer en fait les
brumes à retenir que nous importons de
l'étranger en cinq ans nous allons en
fait mettre un terme à la présence de
pétrole provenant des dictatures 1 une
fois pour toutes
et au lieu d'aider poutine à vendre son
gaz naturel à l'europe pour financer sa
guerre contre l'ukraine un gouvernement
poilievre soutiendra des projets comme
gnl québec nous savons tous que les
québécois en ont une source d'énergie
propre
l'hydroélectricité qu'ils peuvent
utiliser pour fli qui sied la gas
natural sans émission l'europe a besoin
d'acheter de ducasse voici le choix
certains préfèrent que l'argent du gaz
naturel finance les armes de guerre de
poutine moi je veux que cet argent la
finance les chèques de paie pour jean
marc tremblay le soudeur du timing
[Applaudissements]
nous allons donner le feu vert aux
d'exploitation fine minières etc pour
pouvoir construire des batteries des
voitures électriques nous doit permettre
à la technologie de se déployer c'est
plutôt que d'envoyer notre notre argent
dans des dictatures et cela aussi vise
en fait la production alimentaire en
appuyant nos agriculteurs ici au canada
[Applaudissements]
donc les
le gouvernement actuel propose de
réduire toutes sortes de choses nous
voulons en fait
en fait éviter de brûler du pétrole pour
amener l'alimentation s'y est ce qu'on
n'a pas appris qu'il est tout à fait
irresponsable de dépendre du reste du
monde pour pouvoir continuer à vivre ici
notre gouvernement va abolir tous ses
impôts en fait et nous allons soutenir
nos agricultures afin qu'on puisse
alimenter notre population et qu'on soit
nous le panier du monde entier
nous allons restaurer le contrôle des
premières nations sur leur territoire
sur la gestion des fonds toutes les
communautés qui vont devoir déployer des
ressources et lutter contre la pauvreté
et bien auront en moi en ma personne un
allié et non un ennemi nous devons en
fait éliminer les autres obstacles
inutiles en en fait éliminant ou le
l'application complètement désastreuse
arrive canada
et
en mettant un terme au mandat
des mesures sanitaires nous allons
permettre aux gens de travailler
librement et de voiliers jeu comme et de
l'entendre
[Applaudissements]
merci
nous allons redonner de l'espoir aux
médecins aux infirmières aux ingénieurs
et à d'autres qui sont immigrants ici
mais qui ne peuvent pas travailler pour
aucune raison sauf qu'ils viennent
d'ailleurs donc nous allons travailler
avec les provinces à 20khz de s'assurer
que ces personnes au bout de 100 jours
pourront obtenir un certificat en
session de leurs connaissances et non
pas de leurs origines
et aux barres
nous allons appuyer
bourse en fait pour les personnes qui
doivent étudier pour apprendre des
normes canadiennes dont on doit vraiment
faire venir davantage de médecins
d'infirmiers et d'ingénieurs et afin que
ces brillants immigrants et des chèques
plus intéressant plus élevé nous allons
redonner l'espoir des rues
sécuritaire d re qui sont qui font peur
aujourd'hui malgré tout face aux
assassinats à vancouver toronto montréal
et plus récemment même à saskatoon nous
allons nous loi enflé lois actuelles
permettent aux gens de quitter les
prisons plus rapidement et de présenter
un grand danger pour la population au
lieu de dépenser une fortune
et bien
et de d'obliger en fait les gens
enregistrer leurs armes eh bien nous
allons mettre les vrais criminels en
prison
et fermer les frontières aux trafics
d'armes
[Applaudissements]
afin qu'ils puissent reprendre le
contrôle de leurs décisions et de leur
vie au lieu d'être contrôlé par un
gouvernement centralisateur et ebooks à
ottawa vous savez
vous savez
vous savez la langue française occupe
une place toute spéciale dans mon corps
mon père qui a des origines canadiennes
françaises et qui vient d'un village
france espoirs m'a transmis l'importance
de préserver le français dès mon plus
jeune âge en rendez en grandissant
calgary mais heureusement j'avais trop
peu d'occasions de le parler donc j'ai
beaucoup de travail à faire maintenant
je continue de perfectionner cette
langue que j'aime langue fin de panda
triste notre pays avec mon épouse
montréalaise nous transmet ne
transmettant à notre tour à nos enfants
qui vont dans les garderies francophone
nos petits enfants
baby crous et valentina ils auront la
langue française comme première langue
le deuxième langue évidemment espagnol
et après sa troisième langue trois
langues l'anglais
je vais aller plus loin en parlant de
québec je dirais que les consommateurs
de partout au pays ont beaucoup
d'apprendre des québécois les québécois
défendre leur patrimoine leur culture et
leur langue et ne s'excuse de plats la
nation québécoise c'est un tête aux
rockies mme
ouais
mon gouvernement avait
bon gouvernement ne va pas se mettre le
nez dans tout un état fédéral plus petit
va faire grandir des citoyennes du
québec et du canada ce manga vous même
mais un petit gouvernement en fait on
perd mais oui à la population enfin de
réaliser ses rêves de vérifier leurs
voisins et de partage de gagner beaucoup
d'argent d'épargné malgré l'inflation
nous allons restaurer la promesse du
canada un pays peu importe qui vous
aimez ou que vous appelez semi tossing
martin ou mohammed chang charge c'est un
pays où les rêveurs les producteurs
agricoles les entrepreneurs les survie
vers les pompiers les personnes qui ne
cessent de se relever d'aller de l'avant
pour atteindre leur rêve un pays où le
dont deux enfants l'enfant en fait d'une
jeune femme de 16 ans adoptée par deux
des professeurs d'école élémentaire peut
devenir le premier ministre du canada
[Applaudissements]
et non weatherbug ouais mais
dont les noms de john mais que je suis
un canadien libre qui n'a pas peur de
parler qui peut en fait adorer le dieu
comme il l'entend qui en fait peut
s'opposer à ce qu'ils n'aiment pas
qu'ils aient la liberté de choisir les
personnes qui vont diriger mon pays donc
je me promets de vraiment merci beaucoup
de défendre l'humanité mercier
[Applaudissements]
la joute politique fédérale vient de
changer de nom faisait messieurs pierre
poilievre
[Applaudissements]
10 par un sport extraordinaire m'a élu
est dans une course au leadership à 68
pour ça vient de dire aux libéraux je
suis en campagne électorale il avait
entendu
déjà il a donné les grandes lignes de ce
dont il a parlé pendant cette course au
leadership pouvoir d'achat aux canadiens
énergie d'ailleurs gnl débâcle non c'est
un projet que je vais pouvoir voir
ressusciter
jeu soyez m
fiole madeleine une évidence à sa
prochaine campagne électorale dit aux
libéraux prenez note là parce que le
stand
on se demandait comment il allait
remerciés ou
bras vous avez les autres
il isole tout cela mais à dose et des
bons mots et pour monsieur charest il a
choisi le jean charest fédéraliste le
champion du référendum à bien vous avez
vous fait de grandes choses pour ce pays
merci c'était comme la façon
un truc il met face et de leur merci
pour ne pas revenir sur la contreverse
libéral conservateur fédéral et à leur
poignet qui veut mécaniser la partie
magnin appel quand même résume un oui on
s'est demandé s'il allait prendre la mer
tiens poilievre a dit je vous ouvre les
bras donc c'est quand même une
expression qui mène plus forte que
tendre la main effectivement de prendre
la tête de nommer chacun ses adversaires
c'est une chose me parler de jean
charest de parler de sa fable de
redonner aux states et 6 mai
à son adversaire ça a été je pense
habile il devait le faire
malgré une victoire sans appel même avec
60% des voix il est intelligent il est
un policier qui est stratège il ne peut
pas se permettre d'avoir une division
dans ce parti là parce que les
conservateurs de sens très bien lorsque
le parti est divisé ils ne peuvent pas
d'ag et ceux qui avaient des deux sur sa
capacité parce que c'est tout
ont poursuivi la course au leadership
ses talents de communicateur
[Applaudissements]
ils ont été servis là
plus dont ils ont pris des notes ils
connaissent bien la ligue 2 mais c'est
quelqu'un qui peut être un redoutable
adversaire
le vigile et font un tour de terrain
mais bon j'aimerais revenir à la
question jean charest quand même
j'ai trop sont plus maladroit moi de
faire appel seulement à son passé de
bosses messieurs qui en hauteur de 1988
et c'est une façon de le remercier mais
c'est aussi une façon de passer sous
silence
pendant cette campagne
les hauteurs de l'île à paris 2-2 ce que
ces candidats ont apporté pendant la
période il resterait dans ses courses et
de tirs j'ouvre les bras quelque chose
de plus classique et 6 passes le temps
mais ça nécessite de faire on va changer
d'idée par rapport à la course il me
faut cinq ans vieira l'élite et qu'il
admire chez lui ce combat l'époque est
la seule façon pour être maître de
pouvoir les rebelles chose est certaine
façon car d'après vous
c'est pas ma force c'est la technique
mais j'ai eu l'impression qu'ils
parlaient quand même santé les panthers
ce qui est quand même je crois qu'ils en
avaient
mais d'autres pensent sortait de son lit
et c'est un des meilleurs discours
d'acceptation de victoire des deux
chiffres que moi j'ai entendu c'était
bien amorcé un peu trop long
on s'entend mais néanmoins je pense que
les gens qui vont écouter ceux de
l'extérieur qui n'ont pas suivi la
course m'ont trouvé que c'était quand
même élégance jean charest oui plus
élégant que te dis
tortue c'est asus qui tuerait plus que
kim cambrai 10 à l'épaule a touché au
total c'était inoubliable
ceux qui connaissent pas monsieur
poilievre vos serveurs remarquer que tal
singulièrement mieux le français que
stephen harper quand il est devenu cher
que qu'indochine quiron au tournant
faire ce cadeau en tant que parti
conservateur fédéral ce que ces moutures
a eu un chef qui était aussi confortable
il faut remonter
jean-pierre début mais c'est sûrement
aujourd'hui jack deuxième version break
pour la première
c'est ce qu'on appelle excusez moi qu'on
appelle au québec l'oeil anomie vous
deviez fier québécois de défendre notre
langue notre culture qui est un appel
très claire aussi oui mais c'est aussi à
qui le dit et il le lui a des dizaines
de milliers de demandes parti
conservateur pas toujours fait souvent
sur le québec à cet endroit s'il n'y a
pas attendu de les faire comme monsieur
harper avait fait un discours à l'art à
la chambre de commerce la même somme à
moi ce que je n'accepte pas le tchèque
est excellent on voit déjà les thèmes
sur lesquels il va se battre avec
trudeau l'économie l'énergie m le
canadien au centre de gris obtention de
l'état sur les remerciements aux
différents candidats j'ai trouvé que il
y avait sept avec monsieur charest comme
qu'il y avait cent quatorze ans
ces cellules ac c'est l'impression que
j'ai eue il y aurait pu aller piger
comme comme l'a dit hélène dans
plusieurs idées qu'il a avancé ce que
j'ai surtout remarqué c'est la façon
dont il s'est décrit et le décrit sa
femme et c'est là où on voit nos grains
clivage avec les trudeau les deux ont
des origines très modeste sa femme
hochelaga maisonneuve jeudi deux
parrains de saskatchewan et l'on voit
juste restauré la seconde
justin trudeau vient d'envoyer ce
touriste de félicitations et sawyer
poilievre pour votre élection à titre de
chef du parti conservateur ce soir nous
parlementaires devons travailler tous
ensemble écrit monsieur trudeau afin
d'obtenir des résultats pour les gens de
tout pays les canadiennes nathan et même
une méritent rien de moins
comme ce trudeau sociale à la version
officielle la version gracieux c'est
qu'il a dû prendre quand même je dis
ouais lol la croatie viennent changer la
partie vient de changer cet homme là a
des qualités c'est au courrier le parti
voulait vit son moment poilievre mais
doit seulement des jeux sous des aspects
les canadiens auront pas envie de sauce
ce qu'on vit à tout à condition d'en
parler plus tôt aujourd'hui c'est que
les libéraux avaient envie que face à
monsieur poyet ville pense qu'avec avec
lui comme adversaires ils peuvent créer
vraiment une photo ni idéologique entre
les libéraux ou versus qu'ils vont
présenter comme des extrémistes radicaux
des populistes conservateur et pour eux
par style la bataille est beaucoup plus
facile avec un adversaire poilievre
versus dommage mais ce sont des autres
ça qu'on va voir on espère qu'il pleuve
ponza jasper qui plaît monsieur monsieur
poirier a quand même te lis beaucoup
pour loyer
ses adversaires mais je veux juste
revenir sur cette question qui peut être
super il faut quand même le mentionner
monsieur poilievre tonnes minimalement
150 mille dollars depuis qu'à l'âge de
24 ans ils ont été minés s'il y aura les
dents les sécher toute sa vie c'est la
seule radio lui et moi ça me fait
beaucoup rire qu'il se présente
comme je veux revenir sur et j'en suis
avec ce score on voit la 68 g les
résultats dans les circonscriptions du
québec
même en estrie poilievre est numéro 1
montréal il numéro partent chaque
circonscription que l'on regarde abitibi
73 pour monsieur chars et deux symboles
poilievre c'est un de ces quartiers vela
streit deloeuil argenteuil parti doit y
avoir réussi à ramasser et nouveau massa
c'est partout c'est une grande victoire
quand l'équipe croyait vro québec ça
démontre que pierre poilievre il est
aussi il peut aussi être populaire dans
les chais les membres conservateurs au
québec et c'était très très très
important pour le comité organisateur de
pierre poilievre de dire on peut avoir
un parti qui est unie et jean charest
même s'il était peut-être plus populaire
au québec qu'ailleurs n'est pas
nécessairement le seul candidat qui
pouvait avoir dans cette province et ce
statut c'est moi je connais beaucoup de
conservateurs qui m'ont dit je ne
prendrai pas ma carte mans parce que je
ne suis pas capable de voter pour
monsieur charest malgré tout ce qu'on a
dit tout à l'heure sur sa virilité un
peu ras faite avec cette course il ya
beaucoup bien qu'ils n'ont pas oublié la
commission charbonneau au québec
notamment évidemment et qui à cause de
son n'ont pas été capables de voter pour
lui et je pense que ces résultats sont
aussi leur fait l'équipe de foix hier à
dakar même une machine colas à l'afp
faut quand même levé notre chapeau à ces
gens alors qu'ils ont vendu les gens
étaient bafoués tous les je n'ai pas vu
une circonscription monsieur charest
devant qaîda que jamais les premiers
ministres du québec et vous n'êtes pas
capable de mobiliser une équipe ça dit
qu'il te change maintenant les chiffres
parlent bien sûr une raison
oui le cash à rennes a eu l'impression
qu'ils avaient perdu la cote lorsqu'ils
ont vu le taux de participation parce
qu'ils ont et qu'ils avaient alors
qu'ils avaient eu une vente de cartes
phénoménal fallait-il encore que ces
gens là avaient voté quand ils ont vu
que le taux de participation était
d'environ 60% là je pense qu'ils ont ils
ont convenu que la partie était perdue
alors je disais là il ya une nouvelle
joute politique qui viennent d'ouvrir au
canada là mais il ya un nouveau joueur
qui arrive qui lui a hâte d'en découdre
avec les libéraux on va demander aux
libéraux ce qu'ils en pensent premières
réactions à chaud dominic leblanc
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur roy alors vous
avez vu ça
c'est un chef conservateur habile qui
fait un discours
regaillardis est ce que vous êtes
jérolas la galette passez moi
l'expression de la partie vient de
charger les écouter nous pensons pas
énormément tant français aux partis
d'opposition nous sommes le gouvernement
dans un moment difficile dans l'histoire
du pays
des inquiétudes économiques qui sont
très importants en sort d'une pandémie à
travers le monde alors les enjeux sont
sérieux monsieur paul yeves dans sa
course au leadership à avancer des idées
sont pas tout à fait sérieuse d'idées de
suggérer aux gens d'acheter la crypto
monnaie
suggérer aux gens à
série d'idées par exemple permettent à
ses députés de introduire des projets de
lois qui vont restreindre possiblement
la liberté des femmes de choisir après
une série de mesures irresponsables que
monsieur paul yav avait avancé et on
laisse pas les canadiens jugé au fil des
prochains mois vous devrez peut changer
justement là vous parlez de l'avortement
vous devrez peut changer vos attaques le
que les attaques comme monsieur autour
ou comme monsieur ne fonctionneront
peut-être pas construit cet homme et on
verra seïf chef conservateur depuis une
vingtaine de minutes j'ai un peu trop de
conclure ça moi je suis ici pour pour
féliciter monsieur paul yav aussi c'est
un moment important dans la démocratie
de notre pays il deviendra le chef de
l'opposition officielle moi j'ai eu le
privilège d'être au parlement depuis
longtemps c'est une fonction importante
j'étais député d'opposition les
messieurs police gagner une console hfri
avec une série de slogans simplistes est
une chose il a bien faire offrir des
solutions rouvrit défi que font face le
pays c'est tout une autre chose on verra
moi j'ai rencontré un québécois qui a
sorti du congrès juste au moment que
monsieur paul yav a pris la parole je ne
connaissais pas le monsieur mais il me
dire je suis plus capable c'est pas mon
parti
alors j'ai dû québec d'avant moi je vous
disais il est minoritaire le monsieur
que beaucoup de monde qui ont voté
poilievre au nouveau brunswick aussi moi
je pensais que la campagne de monsieur
charest au new brunswick avait des
appuis importants
on dit que c'est pas du tout le cas
alors mais on verra vous avez beaucoup
de temps à a demandé ces questions-là
aux conservateurs nous allons faut que
c'est comme vous savez très bien sur les
coteaux c'est là il ya quelque chose de
sa part et de la démocratie et levons
nous là il y aura un jeu où
c'est un chef qui arrivent avec des
pouvoirs quand même important et on sent
que c'est moins chambre alain que
d'autres chefs avant
c'était les conservateurs penser face à
quand ils ont élu monsieur autour
ou quand ils ont élu à douchy alors oui
à gagny par 68 69 % justin trudeau a
gagné le congrès à la chefferie avec 80%
il est temps qu'on se faisait insulter
son pays à gagner trois élections
exactement mais dominique moi j'ai déjà
lu votre rôle en 2006 car vous avez élu
stéphane guillon comme chef à montréal
émotion c'était puissant qui serait
absent le président vous avez vraiment
intelligent qu'on respecte mais moi je
suis partie des plateaux chalet marché à
montréal j'ai bien dormi soir ce soir ce
soit vous parlez d'un douchez au paris
au loto je sais que vous êtes un homme
objectif était transparent vous
reconnaissez car même à monsieur
poilievre des talents de communicateur
je n'avais pas nécessairement ses
prédécesseurs on reconnais écouter qui a
gagné la chefferie d'une façon éclatante
on reconnaît moi je les ai vus au
parlement quantité militants grandement
monsieur harper ou comme critique à
l'opposition il est très capable dans
les débats parlementaires ont
sous-estimé jamais il faut jamais sous
estimer nos adversaires moi je pense
qu'il met des gens autour de monsieur un
peu qu'ils ont sous-estimé justin
trudeau il y avait des gens autour de
prendre la tête des entretiens qui ont
peut-être sous les cendres sur un peu
contraire alors alors moi je moi je suis
pas ici pour minimiser du tout nous
sommes au gouvernement
nous avons gagné trois élections il y
dix filles sont extraordinaires leur
pays j'allais le dire c'est pas
justement votre plus grand défi c'est
que justement vous avez gagné deux
procès d' action la 4e les gens au
devant de tels échanges minces et c'est
bienvenu une banale dans une démocratie
on verra mais une élection ça comprend
des choix c'est des choix des
différentes politiques des différents
styles de leadership
on verra si les canadiens vont appuyer
le leadership de monsieur paul yens le
parti conservateur la piéce au soir
c'est bien beau mais moi je pense dans
une situation difficile économiquement
des slogans saintonge et y le gouverneur
à la banque du canada
maiko vous aurez jamais fait ça au
gouvernement a transité au gouvernement
de monsieur enfin vous aurez jamais
accepter qu'on va congédier le
gouverneur de la banque du canada alors
ce sont des idées des slogans simples on
verra si au fil du temps les canadiens
trouvent que ces responsables
économiquement pensez vous que justin
trudeau ça va lui donner le goût de
rester encore plus d'avoir poilievre
comme adversaire moi j'ai passé beaucoup
de temps avec lui cet été y compris à
vancouver cette semaine il avait
absolument le goût de rester bien avant
les résultats de ce soir alors ça change
par monsieur trudeau à un travail
important en faire l'essai rien à voir
avec le choix des conservateurs ce soir
mais pierre poilievre arrive avec ce but
ce débat sur l'inflation le coût de la
vie est-ce que vous avez des preuves à
faire là-dessus aussi parce que jusqu'à
maintenant on a l'impression que de
votre côté pour ce qui est de
l'inflation vous parlez de votre
programme de garderies qui existe est de
toute façon avant même que l'inflation
s'emballe donc vous avez aussi une offre
à bonifier avec un adversaire pied qui
est quand même redoutable de vous parler
des garderies monsieur premier va
traiter le programme de garderies comme
un slash fans de l'argent gaspillé ça
c'est pas responsables mais l'idée de
pony fils policiers à l'appui aux
canadiens quant aux questions
d'abordabilité le coût de la vie vous
avez absolument raison madeleine c'est
dommage vous y étiez à vancouver au
conseil des ministres cette semaine
évidemment avec le décès de sa majesté
la reine s'est pas approprié de faire
des annonces quant aux mesures
supplémentaires que nous allons prendre
mais je peux vous assurer qu'on va pas
annoncer que la meilleure façon d'être à
l'abri de l'inflation c'est d'acheter
avec coin qu'ils acquittent oman et ce
n'est que le blanc vous parlez de sa
majesté
décès votre père était gouverneur
général vous avez vous eu l'occasion de
rencontrer la reine j'aimerais avoir vos
impressions sur cette femme on en parle
depuis depuis trois jours mais vous plus
personnel à vous moi j'ai eu quelques
occasions quand j'étais jeune adjoint du
cabinet de monsieur chrétien de
rencontrer sa majesté mais je me
rappelle particulièrement d'une soirée à
rideau hall lorsque mon père était
gouverneur général comme vous dites elle
avait une soirée libre elle était ici
pour la fête du canada il ya 25 ans elle
avait accepté un souper familial
relaxe décontracté et s'était
littéralement un barbecue en arrière
dans ce jardin de rioja on prenait nos
assiettes on allait s'asseoir y avait
deux tables de huit mois j'étais à la
table avec sa majesté et le premier
ministre chrétien monsieur chrétien a
démontré le sénégal tcheka sa majesté
famille avait pris monsieur croc n'êtes
pas au la gorge il a fait rire sa
majesté en décrivant d'ailleurs c'était
moi minimes avaient pris par la gorge
pour démontrer à la reine qu'est ce qui
avait fait le jour du drapeau il y avait
deux roues il ya plusieurs années avant
alors mais qu'est ce qui m'a frappé le
sierrois c'est l'attachement qu'elle
avait pour le canada et sa connaissance
des enjeux au canada de toutes les
régions au canada elle était vraiment
très curieuse
et elle demandait toutes sortes de
questions aux gens qui étaient à nos
tables y avait mon père y avait monsieur
le fait français en français elle
parlait en français alors c'était un mou
c'était un moment pour moi de constater
qu'elle avait vraiment une connexion à
notre pays et on voit ça d'ailleurs à
travers le pays avec la réaction à son à
son décès dominic leblanc merci d'être
passé sur le plateau là c'est moi qui
suis si j'apprécie au plus avant le soir
et au revoir
dimaggio
on le disait dès le début avec sur le
blog les conservateurs avec ce moment
froid lièvre ils n'ont qu'un seul
objectif c'est la victoire contre les
libéraux évidemment ils vont être
entendus même si ça prend deux ans et
demi water le tombait sro paul
évidemment mais je trouvais quand même
intéressant que dans le discours de
victoire ce soit sa femme qui le
présente en parlons beaucoup de la
famille parce que nous on le connaît
pierre poilievre il est député depuis
2004 c'est un pitbull on l'a dit mais
y'a environ 40% de la population que pau
vraiment d'impression sur pierre
poilievre alors c'était un moment qui
était très important oui pour réunifier
le parti mais oui pour se présenter aux
canadiens aussi et pour une et adoucir
son image avec sa femme et deux dans le
présent même si hélène vous l'avez très
bien noté que care poilievre fait pas
pitié avec son salaire depuis 2004 il
devait quand même essayer de montrer un
petit côté j'ai pas toujours grandi dans
la ouate ma femme non plus donc c'est
l'histoire qu'ils essaient de raconter
pour essayer de se vend maintenant au
canada mais on peut le voir même avec
dominique jeu que j'aime beaucoup le la
distinction le clivage entre roméo
leblanc justin trudeau pierre elliott
trudeau et les deux familles qu'on a vu
son épouse et lui on va jouer là dessus
c'est clair mais et les canadiens vont
se faire servir des différences des
familles qui ont travaillé des classes
ouvrières versus des gens qui ont été
chanceuses ce qui peut tout à fait exact
au s'exposerait qui ont été chanceux
aussi qu'il ya des gens qui ont
travaillé très fort pour ce qu'ils ont
eu mais ce qu'ils vont clairement joué
ses cartes leur écart monsieur quand
dominique bien ici puis il traite ça
comme si c'était vrai il vient juste de
gagner leadership je sais qui repart
dans son auto là est clairement ils sont
nerveux nerveux parce que les
circonstances au canada font que ça aide
quelqu'un comme poil hier ce qui se
passe au pays les inquiétudes
économiques et du fiso inquiétudes qu'on
connaît c'est du bonbon pour quelqu'un
comme paul hier jean charest que
qui avec 16 % le disais plus tôt déjà
que c'est dur perdre perdent avec 16
pour ça il vient de twitter
félicitations à pierre poilievre son
équipe c'est maintenant le temps d'unir
les membres devront devons mettre fin au
salissage interne ça c'est une pointe
directement mais ce poids lien va
arrêter de nous traiter comme sont en
tête des martiens ou des libéraux etc
seuls les libéraux en profite lorsque le
parti est divisé ailleurs ce message car
même en disant nous devons mettre fin
aux aguets suis interne via selon ccc
devises ont été blessées monsieur reste
est celui qui le dit le plus ouvertement
publiquement et en privé nous disent
c'est on avait 17 vols contre nous et
c'est qu'ils sont allés beaucoup trop
loin ce que je demandais tout à l'heure
avec 68 pour ça est-ce que c'est
nécessaire de salir ce char est comme ça
puis d'humilier là si c'est ça la
question c'est ça la question des mois
par exemple quand on parle de l'équipe
québec on faisait c'est important de
montrer qu'on vaut galy au québec donc
ça a été une stratégie il voulait en
tout cas aller le plus loin possible
avoir 50% il voulait il voulait je
voulais grave et mélasse la stratégie a
peut être été effectivement à 16 pour ça
on veut revenir ce qu'on discutait
tantôt avec monsieur charest vous aviez
parlé de gagnant gagnant
16 % c'est quand même
ces cassettes j'ai beaucoup de peine
pour lui
c'est pas facile et perdre 60 46 quelque
chose mais 16% c'est un chiffre qui est
vraiment désolant sur trônait au québec
si au québec il y avait eu un score
honorable il pourrait dire bon ben c'est
normal j'ai passé sur la route pendant
tant d'années
au mode d'emploi liées il ya un goût
tous les nouveaux morts dont vote et
poilievre sont vus récemment c'est
absolument c'est une humiliation pour
monsieur chatel il n'y a pas de doute à
y avoir là dessus je sais pas comment il
va passer la soirée le reste est
certainement pas agréable et je le redis
je trouve que pour un ancien premier
ministre du québec et je comprends qu'il
n'est peut-être pas avoir de regrets
mais de revenir en c1 en scène est de
finir sa carrière politique sur un tel
chiffre c'est un sacré camille ciel
celle ci dessous c'est d'attirer ce soit
un mot christian
tourné en fait dernière tournée avant de
laisser les ondes mesdames et messieurs
à des choses plus gai on est samedi
choix mais je pense que c'est important
puis d'écouter le discours de cet homme
qui est maintenant chef du parti
conservateur que les gens vont apprendre
à connaître parce que re des choix
politiques à faire un jour christian
noël on rappelle reprise jeudi de la
chambre des communes exceptionnellement
6 qui circulent pour le moment les
partis d'opposition nous disent que
c'est en discussion avec le gouvernement
le gouvernement ne veut pas confirmer
que c'était jeudi les partis
d'opposition semblent convaincus que ce
sera le cas donc ce sera la première
opportunité pour pierre poilievre de
faire ses classes à la chambre des
communes comme chef de l'opposition
officielle à ottawa il y aura
probablement faute période des questions
cette journée là ce sera d hommage à la
reine ce sera donc sa première présence
ce qu'on a aussi pique nique qui tous
l'heure qu'il est l'arrivée c'est jean
charest qui a réagi sur twitter qui
félicite l'équipe de pierre poilievre
c'est maintenant le temps du thil d'unir
des membres nous devons mettre fin au
salissage interne seuls les libéraux en
profite lorsque le parti conservateur
est divisé et monsieur charest remercie
également les autres candidats n'a la
course
très bien on leur ait eu en duo on
montrer deux fois c'est très bien la
répétition c'est la clé avola
d'opérations de communication et
d'ailleurs cabral hier merci que j'ai
utilisé ce mot
merci beaucoup la wii pierre poilievre
qui répètent les mêmes lignes depuis le
c'est moi madeleine dernier tour de
table rapide il est installé plomb vers
aux kiwis et va répéter des lignes sur
l'inflation y avait déjà commencé avant
de lâcher l'inflation énergie mais moi
je dirais que son l'inflation c'est
peut-être l'atalante talon d'achille est
le point faible des vidéos parce que on
touche aux portefeuilles des gens et les
libéraux ce fonds reprochée par les
contrées servent à tort d'avoir
contribué au problème en éjectant
beaucoup d'argent dans l'économie et les
logements aussi beaucoup parlé du
logement
tomic leblanc avait quand même un bon
point tout à la pratique et il ya
beaucoup de slogans là dessus comme sur
poyet nous parle qui vont rapatrier des
industries manufacturières ici qu'il va
forcer les villes à construire plus de
logements alors qu'on cite une pénurie
de main d'oeuvre dans le milieu de la
construction notamment il ne nous dit
pas comment ils vont procéder donc
monsieur loyal vis très bon à mettre le
doigt sur le bobo à identifier ce qui
est alain pour les jeunes mais on sait
la beauté et la moon walk alone est
sortie merci
j'ai rarement vu un score si ou lé vous
le dire on aura rarement vu ça et mais
quand même sauvé lyon dans les
prochaines semaines ce qui fait avec des
prix du québec à pied charest moi j'ai
pas de réponse ce soir encore très bien
mesdames et messieurs alors c'était
cette spéciale en direct de tahoua le
parti conservateur du canada qui a un
nouveau cherche vraiment de manière
éclatante écrasante
diront certains donc monsieur poilievre
maintenant qu'on va suivre
makhoul force ils viennent parler des
députés du québec ont hâte d entendre
demain après demain ce que je romps le
coup de fil la poignée de mains le
regard du chef en disant j'ai besoin de
vous chers dix députés brian enquête
avec lui mais il 7 qui était pas avec
lui alors voilà on vous laisse aux bons
soins et à rdi des nouvelles à radio
canada d'autres émissions moi je vous
retrouve lundi 17h bonne fin de fans ce
monde parfois
[Musique]